you look who's back it's a Monday and we
are live yes who's excited
who's relieved
yeah I'm relieved I'm actually super
relieved I'm super happy to be here
we got a great show you know things got
a little dicey on uh
Wednesday was it yeah yeah things got a
little bit dicey
but um
we reacted quickly and while we're live
so I mean the proof is in the pudding
and uh all the best to Vatican City do
it live all the we wish we wish I mean
listen I wish Vatican City all the best
in this coming Christmas uh
and they hope they have a jolly
Christmas
I mean you know
just a good guy like that I'm just a
good guy like that you are a good guy a
good guy I am just a good guy like that
yeah but uh anyway glad to be here happy
Monday November 28th boy it's almost
December it's almost holidays time guys
actually
the year's almost up for the show
December 20th is our last show that is
right of the year live from the Vermont
yes I'm doing a live California and
there's gonna be one very lucky winner
of the golden prolapse uh-huh who's
gonna get flown out
and put up
to prolapse live on stage yes yes yes
um they're being flown out as guest of
honor to join us on December 20th live
show
um by the way packs are still available
until December 2nd yeah so the trading
card I think third actually which is
their Saturday
now if you're hoping to click win the
golden prolapse I just want to be clear
that I think that's just being picked
from the first 2500 packs right so
that's actually not on offer not to I
don't want to make it seem like you can
win if you buy it now also uh just to
clarify that it's a it's a golden ticket
that says zilizanka on it it's a lot of
packs have a golden prologue oh I should
be more clear yeah just no just to
clarify it's all good yeah well yeah
then we'd have a thousand winners and
that would be uh very expensive for me
the prolapse I think you can get from
all packs though right is that correct
all the packs have a prolapse card only
if around a thousand packs have a golden
prolapse card I took it down which you
can still get it's like getting a foil
yes and by the way
um
Zach is back we love it welcome back yes
thank you very much yes you hit me with
a well-timed Howie Mandel I took it down
okay and I felt that
I love you how you feeling I'm feeling
I'm feeling better
um I still have the lingering [ __ ] but
um I thought I was dying last week so
what happened to you I caught a flu or
some [ __ ] and my my buddy got it too not
covered not kovid tested like [ __ ]
four or five times yeah yeah
um and I was just coughing up green
mucus and blowing out green mucus and my
voice was gone oh no
um yeah I was pretty sure you know what
happened yes I'm well aware what what
happened the Gabe curse you got curse
bro you got it and I got personal on
Wednesday first the show went so
sideways and I was so scared and it
ruined the rest of my link
um
and and and so I also got a taste of the
curse you got really sick cam got sick a
b you said you also go ahead of curse a
game birthday curse yeah what happened
really bad I don't even know where to
begin I mean last week my hair started
falling out because I bleached my hair
and [ __ ] it up really bad
and uh my PC broke my new pc my
PlayStation stopped working but this
weekend
was the worst I uh lost 440 dollars
I took it out of the ATM and I just I
lost it
what how do you lose how do you take
money at the ATM and then never done
this in my life Lena says that I might
have not even taken you've left it in
the machine that's what she said I don't
know I feel like I possibly took it and
lost wow yeah
I bet you left in the machine I've
almost done that a thousand volumes you
know what I mean how are you gonna the
last thing is uh a little explict
explicit sorry I think it's like
explicit explicit uh I got Lena's
permission to to say this
oh God yeah I was having marital
relations with my lovely wife okay and
uh
I almost I almost uh I broke my broke my
penis
you almost broke your penis
was it a risky position I mean what yeah
I I promised I want to get into detail
there was just some problems with the
Dismount and like
were you afraid you you had damaged it
was it was a painful your penis was okay
now right it's still a little purple but
it was it's purple it was completely
purple and whoa so it got really damaged
the only doctors in the family really
that I'm close with is Lena's brother
and my uncle you show them your dick
breasts no I was describing it to my
uncle which was [ __ ] super awkward
yeah can I see it
[Laughter]
would you show Zach I chose Zach can you
show Zach and then I feel like I feel
like we can't talk about it oh what it's
from a medical standpoint yeah why can't
he shows that
you should show somebody the baby just
to make sure
the feeling though because when it first
happened like Jack's a doctor what my
grandfather was a gynecologist close
enough
it's in the fam yeah
yeah so it's per so it's all purple yeah
I think
um
the blood vessels broke at one point so
what well so what was worse that or the
440
that you've been having a hard time I
think that curse hit you the hardest
because you're the most guilty let's be
real
yeah I guess so
no
wow that's stressful man see the only
time I've had like
I'm gonna say this
sometimes when you're watching like p
word you notice there's this position
the girls do called reverse cowgirl
where they're facing away and the and
the the penis is not meant to Bent like
Bend like that it's bending like really
bad in a really horrible way
and there's times when I've had uh
relations and it feels like my dick is
just not going in a healthy situation
there and so I I don't do that stuff you
know what I mean and frankly I can't
even watch that if I'm if I am watching
uh something it just makes me feel the
pain so I don't know like was it was it
a risky uh position or or just a pure
accident uh Lena thoughts foreign
is comfortable with so
anything I guess I mean Abe's just
letting everything out now you know and
on the last show how he said my mom's
cooking is bad yeah things like that I'm
just like okay whatever he's just
something in the floods
I'm inspired by you Ethan I think you
being really real makes the show good so
thanks bro I actually appreciate that
because it's not easy to open yeah yeah
no it's not open your your heart and
mind like that but it is it does you
know and is Chrome but I I have no
problem putting my life on the cutting
board but I wouldn't ask ever ask that
of you guys but you know I mean you're
you're what can I say you you care about
this show yes so we're so what happened
it was it was in the it was in the
shower oh the shower yeah wow the slip
involved it was yeah so there was whoa
okay whoa that's not that embarrassing
I'm not judging it was it was just scary
I was I was really I I can't remember
the last time I was scared like that
but like throughout the night I was like
holy [ __ ]
and was it did it visibly look damaged
from the minute you got it yeah it did
oh it was yes I hear about this this
hurts whoa see I've never I've never
sustained a penis injury I've never in
my life that was the first one yeah so
wait do you know that it's okay though
that sounds pretty like it's it's
healing I mean you should see a doctor
dude you should get that checked out bro
yeah
yeah
you should I mean does it work no it's
working yeah it's working it's healing
it's I think it's okay hi you should
dick tip you should
wait you described it to your uncle
who's a doctor and he said it's yeah he
said it's fine there's there's at first
he's a little afraid but
any it's funny because I was I was It
was Thanksgiving
and uh my uncle on Thanksgiving when I
was a kid I cracked my head open and he
had to like leave dinner and like Stitch
up my head down the middle my mom was
like God damn it man why you always
[ __ ] up my Thanksgiving with the [ __ ]
funny so you broke that turkey neck huh
I get it yeah dude you should see a
doctor don't play games with your penis
bro as men that's all we have true
yeah I'll go tomorrow I guess
do you think you should see a doctor
Lena you think it's fine no I think he
should for sure I want you to yeah yeah
yeah yeah see you doc see a dick doc I
know a great dentist
doesn't know I mean he can novocaine it
I don't know if that helps
Chad's saying Dr Ridge doctor it's
doctor IDs can we call him can we get Dr
IDs on the phone would you say the
nutrition doctor maybe I'm gonna email
him for free did you take do you have
photos of it no I don't no you didn't
take photos I'm too paranoid yeah me too
I I I'm too scared to take Donnie even
for medical reasons we gotta get Dr IDs
on the phone though if somebody can yeah
we're gonna get Dr Ed's to to help you
out there
wow I mean what really got messed up
dude yeah it's not fair dude I was
really excited to go I had a costume
once again but I got the worst of the
curse
wait your blood
oh yeah okay the cost you keep bringing
up the costume thing
I'm just I was that committed I bought a
costume mm-hmm
I mean Zach we're gonna match
can I just say like I'll stick aside
here like I spoke to Nick and
everything's cool it's kosher I had like
a 30 minute conversation with them
Gabe's fine it's all good no harm no
foul
yeah we knew that we all knew that they
didn't I guess or but we love listen we
love sometimes stuff just doesn't work
out it's fine yes people are asking this
jacket is part of uh the December
collection that is coming out on
Thursday and I love this jacket so
beautiful it even has a custom
logo zip how sick is that yeah it's so
beautiful it feels great looks amazing
thank you Ela for this great jacket love
that
uh uh wow okay interesting sorry about
that AB that sounds horrible and Lena
too I'm sure it wasn't easy for you
either
yeah being castrated
basically right yeah basically it
reminds me of that Dennis Rodman clip
maybe you know what I'm talking about
Zach in the moment immediately I thought
of that Collision I broke my dick show
me this random clip of Dennis Rodman
talking about breaking his dick it's
exactly I think that's what I said too I
think everyone did just like that you're
in good company man yeah
wow
Erica Taylor donated five dollars said I
broke my nose during extracurricular
activities in the shower
yeah be careful with that shower stuff
yeah she broke her nose oh my God that's
a buzz kill do you finish or keep going
did you finish or keep going maybe
you finished
I made it that far I wasn't gonna go
back then oh you're a demon you finished
no wonder your dick's all [ __ ] dude
do you know what I'm not even gonna
blame you bro I would have done the same
yeah wow I think he wanted to finish
also be so I wouldn't be as scared
um I felt so bad that I heard him though
oh my God it was nothing no big deal oh
my God I'm good
whoa well I'm wow okay well that's a lot
of details thanks for sharing anytime
that's incredible Elena's family and
roughly five minutes well
surprise cup a married couple oh I'm
married yeah yeah I mean where's the I
don't think they're gonna be shocked in
fact they're the ones asking you guys
for kids all the time they're
essentially saying we want you to have
more sex yeah there might be in delay
I'm gonna blame I blame them actually
yeah just say I'm fulfilling your desire
for me in fact they should pay for you
to see a doctor
so can I see it or not yeah I'll show
you Zach okay can you guys go to the
bathroom and then report to me Zach
I should I should have I should have
grabbed a a photo when it first happened
because it was a lot worse I'm surprised
how fast it actually healed
so it's looking much better yeah okay
sorry Zach it seems like it's not gonna
happen you know get my hopes up
let's show you well anyway wow what an
eventful um
weekend for AV
and then did you lose the 440 before
after your dick was injured or the next
day so that you were distracted probably
yeah I'm still thinking about my dick
yeah it was the dick injury that left
you absent-minded
[Music]
anyway well thank you wow and then how
was everyone else's Thanksgiving
mine was good I my dick is intact so
that's a consider myself it's not a huge
dub mine too yep
uh yeah nothing to report I I
I'm scared to say it but I don't think I
don't think curse affected me at all I
haven't had any unfortunate events in
the last week yeah and well you keep
saying that you never said you were
gonna go so maybe the curse just passed
well some people seem to uh somebody
made a tier list of an excuse tier list
on the subreddit did yeah and they put
me on [ __ ] F tier saying I had the
worst excuse I thought it was funny but
I thought it was very funny they put you
there but I agree that yours was
horseshits
I don't even need like the point is I
don't even have an excuse because I
didn't there's nothing to be you don't
need an excuse yes I like that well that
has 4 000 points on the subreddit so
clearly they agree uh with what is this
this is about dude I love this first of
all valid excuses I was there and I was
feeling that
but I still got the curse uh Ian flight
the next day got back home late cats
hadn't eaten yet over an hour drive
flight the next morning put him put him
in Sam invalid that was tough that was a
tough one
did you have any curses Ian and Sam and
he gave birthday party curse
I don't think so okay so you guys are
good then and I think
I'll be honest if I got the curse
it's probably a mid curse or my mine is
probably mid and not valid otherwise
nothing bad would have happened to me
right
but I'll take it they says has kids boom
longest day ever boom there's no
babysitter How You Gonna how are you
gonna top that
How You Gonna top that I have kids
nobody's got a week to book one
I'm busy
it's a lots lots going on in my life Man
by the way I watched the clip back I was
not that committed committal oh did you
yeah if you can pull the clip back
because I watched it back I was like I
don't remember saying on the phone with
Gabe was it that episode like when did
you commit yeah yeah during that combo
when we're right okay there's the clip
go look for the clip I said maybe I
should go because you guys had so much
fun last last week gotcha
if you said maybe I feel like you're off
that well there might be there may have
been a [ __ ] it I'm gonna go after that
okay well then that's a commitment yeah
doesn't leave house social anxiety never
intended to go a bill you know that's a
valid excuse I lied when I said I was
going
I love that they put me involved that's
[ __ ] good [ __ ] dude
amid Cameron doesn't know Gabe that well
didn't go last year Olivia didn't want
to go just her and Kim I feel like I
don't know Gabe at all I feel like if we
put Gabe on a call and asked him to
identify me he wouldn't know who I was
send him a photo and say do you know who
this is I've always said we should go
around and have him ask if he knows our
names oh that'd be fun maybe we could do
that because I don't even think we've
introduced ourselves besides his
birthday party last year okay uh Zach
send him a picture of Kim and see if he
know if he knows who that is okay also
the top comment on that threat is that I
had a top excuse too I gotta say what
was your excuse just that I didn't know
him and like if you don't know him you
know you don't know
yeah you don't know
I don't know nothing but I wanted to go
and get to know him but next year
there's always next year and then this
is the bad friend territory this is huge
uh embarrassing elves here terrible
excuse Dan never said he was going
I feel that that that's a really good
that's a really good excuse right it
might be a little bit deranged
um
at the gym and was sweaty over an hour
drive bad friend status because I was in
a pink shirt for my costume that I never
ended up using yeah well you know now
what's pink the flesh your scarf flesh
and your dick true
that got the worst one Pink Floyd cover
band David Gilmore and Roger Waters were
not even there we never got to ask you
about that Zach because you've been gone
right
how were they good show man they played
wish you were here in its entirety and
right it was a good time but for the
record and defending myself I was the
first one to say hey I'm not going so
I'm the life of the party apparently you
are the you're the one that is closest
with them and you are the glue that
binds us all together you're the friend
who without them
right you don't hang there you know what
I mean there's friends who you only hang
out with this person with that person
right no and I I get that
um so I'm sorry I didn't go I am but I
mean [ __ ] happens it Gabe's not mad
all's good mm-hmm
so well you work her so yeah I got the
[ __ ] yeah death
people are saying the sound bites are a
little quiet I don't know I'm adjusting
it oh okay okay
there you go that was interesting that
was fun I enjoyed that yeah sorry Dan
bed friend
shame on you Dan
um well we got so much yes thank you
shame
so yeah the trading cards are up to the
third uh oh today's the black the last
day of Teddy fresh Black Friday sale if
you guys wanted to catch
some insane deals
up to 70 off
I don't know how much is left it looks
like there's a lot left still
uh at least check it out teddyfresh.com
today's the last day it ends at 12
tonight so thank you thank you peace and
love it's a serious serious message
and then here's the other one post I
wanted to read about this from the
subreddit this one had two thousand
points
we were I couldn't tell if this was a
joke or not you guys thought it was a
joke I don't know Read's real to me
you guys think it's a joke
yeah so when Ethan was trying to zoom in
on Jay Leno's feet pick oh this is about
the zooming Fiasco
and Ethan got mad when Dan said he was
over zooming Ethan became Furious and
said look raged I'm not over zooming are
you happy now wait did I say are you
happy now I don't remember I'm sure
that's exactly what happened they've all
thought about this
infinitely more than we have so I'll
take the word for it I saw people
debating even in the comments they're
like well no Ethan proved that the zoom
was bugged because he opened it and then
I was like hell yeah
the screen cut that Dan he rolled his
eyes and I noticed he was about to say
something vile
[Laughter]
about Ethan but bitch's tongue then he
just said whatever you're right and it's
very in a very I have to say something
vile what like what could you do like
anti-semitic or like yeah what could be
that vile
bro I hope you've something about B
wording the V yeah
[Music]
that'd be that would be a problem if you
said that
we don't do that anymore
uh then he said whatever you're right in
a very annoyed annoyed tone and looked
off screen as if he was looking at the
door to walk out right then and there
I had to take a break from watching the
episode this tense moment was really too
much for me I'm still shaking a little
bit they the shaking has to be that's
why I thought it was a joke it's a joke
that last line
the show's in Jeopardy and I hope
everyone enjoys this episode like the
last because it may very well be
um but why but it's just like a random
comment you would put that much effort
into writing maybe maybe I guess it's
more like at this point the shaking is
the only tip off I would have believed
it other than that I'm literally shaking
right now I mean look there's people
like that Demi Lovato literally said he
ruined her whole world we're gonna get
the yogurt she wanted the week if I read
that I think it was a parody too but I
left that yogurt
yogurt that's what I'm saying you know
well all the comments are about Jordan
Peterson and then he brushed his pubes
across my face yeah that was good and I
had a hard time the rest of the week and
I'm still shaking
and then my fave of course was the whole
copy pasta I dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool there was also a river in
real life she had been a victim of
Alzheimer's disease and had regressed
before her death a semi-conscious state
and they dreamed as well she had lost
her capacity of self-control her genital
regions were exposed dimly it had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair yeah
and so I dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool which was also a river
yeah her genital region was exposed
dimly it had the appearance of a thick
mat of hair
that one that one
yeah
hey you guys see um
oh yeah I need to step away for a bit
this is about on uh
Wednesday the last show was
was tough you know I
said some things that I shouldn't have
said
and there was a good chance I was scared
all I ruined my whole week I wasn't sure
if I was gonna be here or where I was
going to be
and uh
I just don't know why I can't joke about
[Music]
um the Pope
he's got
I'm straddling the line I'm about to
straddle the line too close so I'm not
even gonna do that
I'm not even gonna do that
let me just say this picture's worth a
thousand words
how you gonna hurt this man
I have no intentions of doing that by
the way but
dude this man
cruises around in this [ __ ] thing yo
the dude could probably withstand a
nuclear hit
right just never really
not to speak it's kind of a fire vehicle
I wonder if I could get one of those
Mercedes yo is that thing yeah I wonder
if that's retail
what do you think that MSRP is at
silence okay all right let's not even
talk about that
thank you
yeah see he didn't put mobile costs 565
000 oh you can buy it [ __ ]
is that expensive some CNN article what
is 500 Grand the glass it's probably
yeah it's like a custom chopped like
limo G wagon with a bulletproof glass
it's expensive and they probably even
have like blast shields on the bottom
for grenades you know what I mean yeah
that thing is a beast bro I would take
one of those that'd be so epic
where I wonder what's an occasion I
could use that [ __ ] man
so dope
yeah anyway whatever
he's he's fine bro
yeah anyway oh Dr is is gonna call on
okay
you want him now from his phone or he
said 20 minutes he'll be home yeah let's
get him on the phone yeah we could do
the phone let's just get it's you know
just a quick thing yeah
yeah so
anyway I was scared
and I don't know how the b word keeps
slipping out but I'm trying I'm I'm
swearing off the B word
no B words anymore that's what you're
stepping away from right that is what
I'm stepping away from stepping away
from saying the b word
I'm also planning on stepping away
apparently I'm supposed to get unbanned
on Twitter because Elon Musk tweeted out
or he did a poll did we show this on the
podcast yeah we talked about it last
week in fact we voted live on yeah okay
so so the poll passed and he says
starting this week is going to start the
amnesty
so I have plans to step away from age
Productions Twitter and become a
permanent Elon Musk parity account so
I'm also stepping away from that for a
bit
no bombs in chat guys stop
I don't see any bomb emojis in chat okay
please
we're serious about this now stop
I don't need Isis in my chat dropping
bomb emojis okay we're wholesome people
and we don't do that
no B words in chat guys no see now
they're doing peace loving bombs
that's not funny
stop it
stop it
no bombs in chat you guys come on
this is unbelievable it's just bombs now
you guys
oh great
cut them off that's YouTube's fault
don't worry
okay Hamas what's going on here
freaking Al-Qaeda
or if really I should say uh
what do you Ethan Klein
and no swirls damn it
so that's what I'm stepping away from
but no but seriously I'm very glad to be
here man I was I think we were all a
little bit spooked let's be real
and certainly people did try
um
it didn't have the same oh here uh
as a long time viewer Journey baby
recent member here I love it it's my
80th 28th birthday let's go
let's go
yeah this situation didn't have the legs
as like the last one they really went
crazy on the Ben Shapiro one I guess
because I was like oh he's attacking one
of our own you know
this was just a joke about the Vatican
it's a whole damn country but look at
them a quartering's thumbnail again we
I'm obsessed with his thumbnails and he
did not disappoint bro Ethan Klein drops
another b word threat Ethan Klein
unhinged and likely banned again for
threats
check out the details dude so I guess
I'm wearing some kind of Insurgency
outfit I have a bomb a cartoon-esque
bomb Dan is freaking the [ __ ] out and I
love the pope who has his hand up to
Shield himself from there
and uh that's [ __ ] great I'm not even
gonna hate on that thumbnail bro the
quartering is a little IQ inbred loser I
think so too but he said it so I'm not
even gonna feel in the drain
uh he tweeted out Ethan Klein did it
again we should shut down the Catholic
church and b word the v c
Viet Cong
not like a terrorist attack he literally
can't help himself
yes but then he actually kind of a based
uh quartering take
of course it was a joke it's just you
know Ethan doesn't give other people the
benefit of the doubt so it's hilarious
they deleted the clip re-uploaded so I'm
sure it'll be fine but maybe they should
consider consider going pre-recorded
I don't know why he I don't know
everyone thinks that I'm trying to get
people banned over jokes I don't think I
do that I don't think I've ever done
that
I mean the only people who I've been
like yay I'm glad he's banned is like
they're not joking I mean I don't know
Alex Jones joking I mean I don't think
so
at least not outwardly
yeah but that was kind of based the the
subtext
oh you know what we're doing now I say
this we got did you order the uh kill
switch
I haven't ordered it yet I'm talking to
uh the vendor it's it's specialty stuff
so it's not like you can just order it
directly so this this incident motivated
us
we're getting a very expensive piece of
Hardware that they use in like
the NBA and it allows you to erase part
of a live stream it's very interesting
it's high-tech stuff it's not high tech
at all it's existed since the 70s oh
come on bro I'm trying to it's expensive
yeah it's everybody's familiar with it
on a level I mean it's a dump switch
it's it's what it's what prevents people
if they curse on broadcast television or
something so that they don't get banned
or fined by the FCC
yeah so we're going to implement that
and that's hopefully going to help
and you all can dump me is everyone
gonna have a dump button no it'll just
be me and I and I actually think that
you should have one yeah I'd love that I
call them like you'll have one on your
desk and when you say something and you
immediately regret it you can just tap
the button that's so awesome I love that
I have a take back live
and it won't maybe yeah it will I
shouldn't give it to you because I don't
want you to start relying on it
I think it's a good idea for me to have
or or well if it's 30 seconds I could be
like damn yeah yeah maybe you know what
that's a better idea I'll have I'll have
control of it I think I don't know but
but the only thing I don't like about it
is that the kill switch adds a delay and
I'm wondering what do we want like 30
seconds seems like a long-ass delay for
the stream well I was going to do some
experimenting so you know YouTube
already has a built-in delay
um that we use it for stability purposes
in case little dropouts in the internet
happen it allows it a buffer to be able
to catch up but you can actually lower
that
um when you set up the stream to almost
being in real time kind of like how
twitch is only on like a second or two
delay yeah so if we move to a shorter
delay in YouTube and then add the delay
would that be nice it effectively would
be the same oh that's the way that we're
used to here let's test it somebody
start let's do a test we don't have it
no I'm going to see what's the delay I
know don't worry I know that somebody
start a stopwatch on a second
I have an idea of how to test it okay
okay everybody type one in chat let's
just see ones in chat
did you start it I did I did like a
second after you said that
oh well it's a little late now
there they they're doing it now how long
was that I mean 10 seconds
at The Adult Swim live streams uh we had
a delay button too but that was because
the callers would call in and make B
threats and you know yeah really yeah so
it's funny to be on the opposite end of
that where the host is I'm the one the
bean threats are coming from within the
building this time [ __ ]
I don't know why I keep doing that I
don't know if it's like neurological at
this point it's weird
I mean you do have Tourette's not bro I
don't yeah let's say he's a threats
we should just start leaning in yeah
let's lean into that and then if I ever
get in trouble I'll just say ableism on
YouTube because uh swedenita gets away
with all kinds of crazy Wilds so true
and she has Tourette's like me I'm
disabled are you disabled
what I'm sorry
I'm disabled disabled you need to get a
doctor's note I have doctors now we'll
send it to YouTube and be like yeah I
feel disabled
wait what else do I feel today
I felt worthless
today I feel uh Qatari today I feel Arab
right today I feel uh gay oh come on I
felt gay
okay okay
by the way thank you for the Dono
shashisha
[ __ ] oh she got cheated on the dumped
man [ __ ] that idiot loser what the [ __ ]
as a cradle Catholic you have my
blessings thank you so much for that I
got the B card
no shot is still spamming one
um there is a uh there's a doctor yeah
let's get Dr IDs on the line I don't
want to keep him waiting a doctor Edge
is on the wine to diagnose abs
music that we we gotta like get like a
Dr Ed's theme song that we can play
anytime we need to get one for our theme
song
like uh p p needs a theme song all right
here we are oh okay dang you really
gonna hit us with that doctor it's my
girlfriend or my wife watches this show
how's it going hey sweet family what's
happening hey doctors how's it going you
good
yeah you caught me in the middle of uh
cycling and I was on Tick Tock live and
uh some of your fans came in like oh my
God got H3 I was like oh okay well
thanks for thanks for making the time
for us we always appreciate hearing from
you by the way we're having we we worked
out we talked a few times ago when you
called in you're debating one of these
um meet doctors who say just eat meat
this guy's a [ __ ] lunatic and you are
coming on this show to debate him we got
that worked out Dan
yeah so yeah we got the date it's uh
uh I'm playing 13th December oh there
you go this is exciting and last time he
said I want a more serious platform but
what happened he changed his mind
well what I think happened was um he saw
liver King right yeah yeah and uh yeah
he must have thought you know what
because the Topic's already been covered
so you said to me why don't you reach
pakata A3 and uh we'll organize a day
well that's nice
yeah liver King's probably his God I
mean
uh they're in business together I
believe oh they actually are in business
yeah what do they say what do they sell
ground up [ __ ] beef bone like what
could they possibly sell
yeah it's the supplements I believe yeah
they're trying to be rich as [ __ ] yo
it's their Primal Primal range of not so
natural supplements and pills I got the
blood Vitality right here dude let me
see and remind us how how many pills
does he say You're supposed to eat 80 a
day right no six a day but I got three
different variants that I gotta take
today you have to take 18 pills
supplement the day I've been subprime I
haven't been taking them though so 18
[ __ ] crazy money holy [ __ ] so what's
actually what's actually in it
uh probably sugar yeah
sawdust I believe yeah
New Zealand grass-fed blood bovine what
they fed it blood they fed wait they fed
the blood grass I guess so yeah we got
it's red and white blood cells he me
iron
uh immune proteins New Zealand grass
spread delivered is it white and red
blood cells in all blood why do they
need to they don't need to say they need
to disclose that both blood cells are
there right Dr Ed's oh they well it
depends are they separating aspects of
your blood oh so they're spinning it
spinning it really fast and giving you
one component I'm not sure okay so they
they're doing both so you're getting a
value pack okay good I'm so glad I get
both types yeah
and it's also got a spleen and uh
gelatin that's a gelatin right very good
yeah does it say anything about asbestos
or rat poisoning uh it's two two tiny
print for me to read okay okay so no
asbestos that we know of mercury or it
could be it's just too too tiny print
you know I got it yeah so um
we called you today we we hit we threw
up an emergency signal for you because
our our friend and a crewmate here AV
actually had a penis related injury over
the weekend
oh wow and um oh yeah we were saying he
needs to see still in tax
barely it sounds like it's Holding On by
one ligament it's there
but he's okay he hasn't seen a doctor I
guess maybe he's embarrassed but we're
all like you need to see a doctor do
this sounds really bad so
um Abe do you want to describe your
injury to Dr IDs and he can help get a
diagnosis on this or I know obviously I
I don't want to put you in a spot I know
this isn't like an official diagnosis
just friend a friend right yeah
so I mean are you uh
trying to do an examination right now a
lot what's going on
I whip it out ABC I think he'd send you
a picture I'm sorry we ruined your your
uh cycle
um cycling but uh yeah so I just
I don't know I they my crewmates felt
like I should get a diagnosis or Yeah
official diagnosis yeah okay so explain
what happened I was uh engaging in
intercourse with my wife which is hello
because we're married just forget we're
here baby just if you're in the doctor
office you guys are talking nobody's
here
we were in the shower
and uh there was a problem when she was
uh
dismounting
and there was a little bit of like
you know oh yeah and immediately I
believe a bunch of blood vessels broke
and okay tip region the tip of the dick
the tip yeah it was the tip
oh my God the tip yeah yeah I thought it
was the stem no stem was okay stem
stayed strong what yeah did you hear uh
did you hear an audible sound yeah it
was me I'm dick tip so besides that no
okay did you feel like a crackle or pop
yes
snap crackle and pop oh
okay yeah is there a significant
significant bruising bleeding there was
it significantly went down though
I'd say okay yeah and the area
this was
Thanksgiving night so okay it's been
four or four years ago it's it's I'd
probably say a quarter remaining of what
it was
and it's a lot okay it's a different
color yeah
did you do anything for it did you have
you done anything for it so far prayed
that's it pray
you've not taken anything you've not put
any ice on it or whatever random stuff
no
okay he finished by the way doctor after
the injury I don't know if that's
relevant
that no that actually is yeah because
that [ __ ] that shows a preserved
function okay that's good that's good
yeah that's good
have you
have you had any limited
his penis is purple but his blood his
balls are not blue where's we're being
said
oh okay
[Applause]
um so going to the going for a Wii is
fine right or not yeah
okay any any blood when you go any
difference in color no everything seems
normal
yeah okay so all functions are fine
right are you able to are you able to
get an erection yes
okay
right
well
to be honest I would I would probably
still get an examination by your local
family doctor
um if all if all sanction is preserved
and it's not actually affecting your
quality of life in terms of you know
pain it's not it's not stopping you
sleep it's not you know causing blood in
your urine it's not stopping you getting
an erection
um and it seems like 75 has already
improved so far right yeah so yeah so in
that case it's probably what we call
self-limiting
um in the context of medicine which
means basically it can resolve by itself
right just like a cold or like a flu so
that's a relief
that's great to hear that's good here
but I would still just to be safe
because obviously you know if it was me
and you were in the hospital then I
would I would obviously examine it I
would you know ask you to do some things
or whatever you know just to just to
check whether it hurts whether it's
tender whether there's bleeding whether
there's still bruising right um just
check that you know the sensory kind of
you know sensation around the area as
well check the nerves are all intact so
I I would still just to be safe but it
sounds it sounds like you should recover
your aubergine pretty soon
nice nice all right thank you thank you
and it looks nice that's good I like
that that was that was informative and
if I can't make it to a doctor is it
okay if I just have like say my
co-workers Zach take a look do you think
or do you think I should go to
professional
well if they're a doctor then I guess my
grandfather was he's very popular well
well what about sending a picture to Dr
is would you be okay with that doctor
um but but I mean it my my advice would
still be the same yeah you can't examine
him right yeah yeah exactly you need
examination yeah I'm going I'm going by
what you said which is 75 you know
bruising improved so right yeah yeah all
right well that's really good advice I
appreciate it and maybe let me ask you
this when you brought this story up did
you think I could bring take it this far
of course you did you knew I could turn
this into the whole hour yeah I
appreciate that Dr Israel I appreciate
how uh readily available you are it's
just so it's so great and you're just
you're the best doctor where would we be
without you
it's all good my friend you know I get I
get lots of love from the H3 family so
it's a pleasure
well-deserved look well I look forward
to um the debate on the 12th is that was
the 13th the 13th which is just two
short weeks from now oh that's gonna be
so fun and just as a preview
um he is actually a doctor who believes
in the all meat diet he's one of these
guys that talks about how like
vegetables and vegetable oils are like
killing you and all kinds of wild [ __ ]
right so you guys would be debating
these kind of this kinds of weird
medical misinfo that we see on Tick Tock
yeah so so basically we've we've we've
had a chat already uh on Zoom I'm going
to have another one in a week's time
just to basically tease out exactly what
propositions we're debating right okay
that's cool so so the two propositions
obviously I'll send you I'll send you
them before we have the debate great but
the first proposition is around seed oil
so vegetable oils and his idea is that
they are are you know a significant
driver in heart disease and
cardiovascular disease right and I would
obviously push back against that so that
seed oil also all your canola oil your
safflower oil sunflower oil all these
readily available you know
commercialized oils and the second
proposition is that he claims that
vegetables and the stems leaves seeds
and roots of plants aren't all that
beneficial to humans
um because they contain defense
chemicals
and uh in specific you know
gastrointestinal issues or scenarios
then they're not very good for you right
and I would push back against that as
well so those are the two propositions
we're going to be discussing and it's up
to you guys to maintain the peace
maintain you know the good conversation
and make sure no one starts throwing Raw
Liver around well you know you can
depend on me to keep the peace
he is a respectful King never pushes I'm
a well-known debate moderator of
credentials no but actually what I want
to do is prepare Clips different video
clips of like liver king or the
carnivore guy or Joe Rogan or Jordan
Peterson where they are making you know
what I perceive and I'll be upfront with
him just in the for the sake of
transparency because if he's coming on
here to debate I want to give him the
benefit I'm saying look I'm just going
to be disclosed to you up front that I'm
you know I do have a bias going into
this but I'm going to be I'm gonna be
fair as I possibly can be uh to let him
respond and you know it seems like he's
respectful so we shouldn't have a
problem he seems like a it's been very
professional yeah
I don't think so I don't think it should
get heated in a weird way or anything
like that but no no it just he's you
know he wanted to have a chat just to
basically you know kind of uh understand
each other's positions better because
email is not very conducive to you know
that that style of conversation yeah so
I'm sure it'll be fine it just depends
if you know that you guys try to I don't
know hype things up a little bit about a
certain point then sometimes he might
not take a liking to that so that's
that's all I'm that's all I'm saying so
well yeah so I'll do my best but it's
gonna be fun I look forward to it I was
hoping I was wondering if you guys could
each get in a dunk tank or something
like that would you be a do you think
you could he would be open to that
what's that oh it's like you sit on a
bench and then people throw balls at it
and if you hit the bullseye you fall in
the water so it would just be hooked up
to my I would control them and you both
sit on dunk tanks
how would I how would that look I'm just
kidding that'd be that would be very
hard to figure from the UK we could get
things we could figure it out though
explore all options yeah there's options
all right thank you yeah if I was there
in person I would happily do that that'd
be awesome okay so let's check with him
if he's okay with don't think okay
all right doctor Edge you're the best
thank you amazing cheers guys thank you
so much see you then see you then
bye-bye bye that was great that was
actually super super unhappy for me if
you feel you actually feel better after
that yeah I feel I feel feel me yeah
Lena how do you feel about that that
went well right really yeah yeah it's
good to know
good man you're not gonna see a doctor
are you you just be real
we'll see I Pro you know after that I
probably wouldn't just because you know
it's like such a pain in the ass yeah
I'm not I'm not convincing one with the
other I'm just being real about yeah
yeah
you would Dan
oh Cam send something
okay this is interesting
um
here is something
it is the Susan it's okay I got a b word
histrionic disorder this is why we
didn't get banned I got history on heck
this is a Jimmy Lee meme hey you're
ableist
I got Tourette's Syndrome one of my
ticks is to threaten to blow things up
it's not serious it's just the old-timey
type of joke work with me
Eat Your Heart Out Vatican City I'm
looking at you Pope
[Music]
that's awesome
hey work with me Vatican City I kid the
Catholics
I kid the Catholics I would love to see
Jimmy do Street comedy oh oh I kid the
Catholics If Only They Weren't into
kitten with the kids or something with
kid yeah there was something there yeah
there was something there it needs a
little work sorry cam go ahead I I would
love to see an episode of dangerously
funny he's throwing Jimmy Lee and
Vatican City that would be fire yeah
probably not a lot of English competency
there I think I think Italy is one of
the lower English literacy oh but that
is a that's a tourist Hot Spot oh you
think so
but I want to see him doing it to like
the authentic Vatican City residents not
tourists you know what I mean there's
only one resident of evidence yeah
Vatican City is like a city block it's
like it's like a complex it's a very the
fact that there's people that live there
there's houses there's only one legal
civilian of Vatican City no way Pope
Francis yeah
at the Joker Church
Vatican City population 825.
you can live there without having a
residential yeah I think there's houses
there I mean not a lot obviously 125
[ __ ]
you know
there it is 806 as of this year so
let's send Jimmy out there that could be
a worthy cause
maybe maybe we just send Jimmy like
China just get people's reaction to him
all around the world send them to
you know what I mean send them to Brazil
we're filming comedy TV worldwide that
would kind of be everything he's
speaking Portuguese how about you suck
on these ah yeah I just you get killed I
think someone would kill him say where
where would his act get you arrested or
or arrested or like
hurt just arrested just arrested I mean
China Russia yeah so okay you just want
to put him in jail
I mean if we send him to like uh if we
could get him like detained Moscow an
extended right where's Putin there uh he
would smuggle a phone into there and get
his posts up North Korea they do tours
in North Korea maybe yeah he could go as
long yeah they like quite influencers
over there
that would legit be dangerously funny on
the streets of Pyongyang if he could do
his work with me to a North Korean
propagandist tour guide that would be
everything hey The militarized Zone
demilitarize these These Nuts I thought
comedy was illegal here
holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
damn I wish North Korea had more of a
sense of humor this was such a buzz kill
some dude went there and like took you
heard about this guy he took like a
something out of the bathroom for a cute
sake he was an American and they put him
in a a Work Camp and he [ __ ] and then
sent over like his vegetative body and
he died and she was like so [ __ ] up do
you remember that what's his name his
recent development
he was in hard labor for like six years
and then they just gave his vegetative
body over it was real that's what they
do man they're [ __ ] scary
send them to a Work Camp work with me
yeah call me just ain't what it used to
they're too woke over there in North
Korea ain't got no fun and just a joke
it's just an old-timey joke too woke
glorious leader more like glorious
beater of these
[Applause]
no
good
hey is there anything to eat around here
where's all the food
Kim jong-oo is pretty fat where are you
getting all the food from
yeah okay whatever
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
um so anyway we're talking about
um the reaction to my Wednesday episode
so we were talking about
um the quartering
Jeremy we showed his uh masterful
thumbnail
but here he takes a jab at Dan I
wow what could you say about Dan I
wouldn't say jab I was gonna say well
wait until you see it I don't think it's
really a jab oh you think he's
complimenting you well let's see let's
see that's what it says in the dark I
know I'm sure this guy hates me well hey
shut up we match
Dan you can always come work with me man
you could even do it remotely
because he seems to understand the
actual rules of YouTube
I did it again
now the I'm going to tell you the real
reason that they don't go pre-recorded
okay this is great the one fix to this
is you can make all the edgy jokes you
want but they have to be pre-recorded
like I've talked about having like Alex
on my show for example all right Jones
and people want to have them on because
they want it to be alive but ask
yourself why they want it live
they want super chats
bro what are you talking about I was
waiting for him to have like a very like
you know incisive analysis it was so
dumb and no that was the worst possible
thing you could have thrown out there
it's all done there's no soup there's
like very little the 400 uh yeah that's
really worth it but no we do it come on
I explain it's the excitement it's a
better product I love doing it oh he
says I'm greedy okay go on
so that's why it's live he knows that if
you were just to not you sound like a
giant [ __ ] dude who's afraid to go on
live sound like a little baby ass [ __ ]
who's not ready to deal with like the
real world out in the trenches bro I'm
on the front line of content creation
live [ __ ] well that's how we do
it he did do it live but he just ended
up pissing in his basement exactly if
you think I'm bad at live the last time
you did you waffle Stumpy [ __ ] down your
basement
gutter as you cried about your wife
going out for pizza without you maybe
I'm gonna pee in my trash can
and I don't you know
you want to go work for a quartering I I
oh no I was just gonna say I I don't he
said this guy probably hates me I don't
think I hate the quartering I don't hate
quartering yeah he's too much you're too
harmless dude you're just he's a goon
you're a goon yeah I don't think you're
like a dangerous Force sir what do we
say about him he's an inbred oh oh yeah
well he said that didn't he Olivia has a
good amount of compassion for him I'd
say I think sometimes he is lovely I
think that he says nice things to you
guys sometimes you're right he is
sometimes lovely I think that last time
um we talked about him I said some
beautiful things and um
and he just has love for Dan in that oh
where's your job offers that's feeling
weird I wonder would it be like to work
for a quartering you can work remote so
you have an offer you have a standing
offer for another job I know Kermit
Peterson just donated 45 pounds pounds
I'm donating just to piss off Jeremy
thank you Kermit Peterson this is why
we're live We Do It All For You Kermit
for your 44 pounds
then why were they removed somebody said
Dan hates Jimmy Lee and doesn't hate the
quarter in the juxtaposition kills me
well that is interesting very different
energy it definitely is causing more
harm societally than Jimmy Lee uh yeah I
mean maybe but on a personal I don't
know but yeah but at home in his
basement not to their face saying yeah
it's such different it's such a
different things and honestly I mean hey
did such a strong word I don't know if I
hate Jimmy Lee I don't find him very
annoying extremely annoying
yeah but I I see what you mean Olivia he
he always slips in like really beautiful
and lovely things he called Ela Goddess
that one time
yeah that joke could have got cut and it
wouldn't be like congratulated you on
your views too yeah he was super stoked
about me getting more views well that
was very selectively edited yeah
it was like we need do something
because it was like well he actually got
a good actually those are great views
those are great views
immediately after that I cut that it was
just because he did it for money yeah
you know so just that he got a bunch of
super chats from it and everything I
thought you guys just fell for my edit
uh yeah well no he loves me don't say
that he loves you cat damn can we get a
DPI check
oh people have been missing that DPI
announcer man uh-oh they've been
thirsting oh no 700 and DBI I'm not
doing it didn't we find the voice actor
we're gonna hire him right you guys
Reach Out
yo let's get him to redraw Peterson uh
the pubes one Grandma's pubes here we go
my grandmother's pumes wait when
I missed that where did we find the
voice someone found him DPI
what is he he's got an IMDb no he's a
professional we'll have to reach out
through a professional yeah someone
emailed the DPI people and they were
like I'm so happy to tell you that it's
actually a close friend Etc so someone
needs to reach out immediately he has
our website with the contact page and
everything yeah so let's contact him and
I want to get him we can get him to do
all kinds of [ __ ] bro we can get him
read the Jordan Peterson thing we could
get him I mean that it's at Limitless
DPI that guy [ __ ] man that guy [ __ ]
hard yeah yeah I don't doubt that anyway
Clarity parody parody covering their
face this person they all know everybody
why does everybody in the room know
YouTube terms of service better than
Ethan Klein a guy that's been on the
platform since the beginning a guy that
has had the CEO of listen I know the
terms of service very well
that being said sometimes knowing the
rules hey sometimes you got to know the
rules to break them you know what I mean
no bad idea YouTube on his show of
course no she was never on my show
[ __ ] stop that
she came to meet us one afternoon for
like 10 minutes
he's with you that's pretty much not
even I don't the good in this video I
think except the Epic uh opening at it
but actually I don't think we should
show that actually but yeah let's not
show that let's not show that she edits
it but it's still just to play oh yeah
there's too much like yeah
so but but you know the quartering who
we love whatever but keemstar
this is
my friends let me just set you up here
now we've been on a keemstar embargo and
I pledged a while ago and I've been
sticking to it pretty well that we
wouldn't talk about him he's boring he's
irrelevant
you know he doesn't even upload anymore
he now does a show that gets like 10 000
views it's sad it's sad
and um
I promise I wouldn't talk about him
unless something like career ending
insane happened and well it did
something so [ __ ] good happened I'm
busted
Christmas came early dude so he went on
a friend of his or I don't even know if
it's a friend a Creator or small creator
piss BL I would say close to blackout
drunk
and the stuff he said on this if he had
a career left it would ruin it
including here let me just give you an
example of one thing he said and it was
so bad that he here they just watch this
real fast I'm drunk okay welcome yo it's
the night before Thanksgiving right it's
the biggest stricken night of the year
how the [ __ ] are you not drunk
yeah I love you too Ally [ __ ] I
guarantee you got some prime puss all
right wait wait this isn't the one I I
sorry I'm getting ahead of myself this
is the one I want you guys to hear
yeah I'm gonna go back and do that I'm
drunk oh wait this is the right one
welcome it's so cool it's so long
here just play the sound bite then of uh
hymns talking about high school girls yo
bro I'm at this high school girl that I
was hot as [ __ ] tonight yeah let's
go dude
let's go he's talking about how he met a
high school girl that was so hot tonight
yes I know he said that [ __ ] he said
that [ __ ] I'm drunk indeed
and um
so he went on his buddy's show and was
such a disaster he made him he made him
either unlisted or turn it to members
only or something but obviously we have
we have ears and eyes everywhere
somebody posted that clip to the
subreddit or you know we got family
strong family sees all
but before I get into that I want to
show what he said about uh Wednesday
Wednesday's episode Kim start tweeted
out and this is so interesting
he tweets out Ethan kleinformation
podcast calls for another uh T
tick this time he wants to b word
Vatican City
and he posted a video
of him twiddling his little toesies
watching the show by oh Philip DeFranco
would you say Dan is still better but I
like this look for you Ethan nice moves
okay thank you uh Phillip
[Applause]
remember that Ethan
I remember it
um
listen Phillip uh this is progress the
last time
there was no compliment for me just
straight you love Dan uh is better than
me so I'll take it thank you Phillip
appreciate that
Philip DeFranco everybody
Super Chat
we got him we got a Super Chat guys this
is why we're live thank you baby I love
you
so
I love you too buddy I know the
feeling's mutual
yes so um sorry I don't know what just
happened
Boomerang out my laptop yeah so he
rushed to Twitter to post this because
if you guys saw the episode we had this
mishap and then we immediately ended the
stream and uh
erase the video and then re-uploaded it
and so he didn't have a HD version he
only had this vid of him
tweedling his little toes in bed and
it's so embarrassing I'm not gonna play
the audio because obviously it was
that's why we removed it in the first
place but he's got these tiny cute
little elf feet
and he's just watching put hit me with
the lullaby music that was good and he's
watching by himself in the dark and tell
me this man's not the biggest fan you've
ever seen in your life
this man is snuggling up with a good
episode of H3 podcast
and I love that for him
I was just wondering does he always
watch with the lights off
or is that part of the tradition well H3
podcast is his comfort show so I would
say yes
maybe too much comfort maybe we don't
know where his pants are that's all I'm
gonna say we don't know if it passed his
ankles or
you mean his way so you could see the
cuff here
yeah but I mean the top of them though
crap they may be down somebody named
Sora has been a member for 50 months
that's insane our previous stop was like
35.
yeah this one have we even had it on for
that long
I guess so before you guys made it a
thing I think it's 4.1 turned it on by
itself yeah I remember it was just kind
of like passively on and we never used
it or talked about it but four years
that's crazy that was like the very very
beginning of the podcast yeah
yeah
so here's fangirl uh keemstar and having
a beautiful night with this Comfort
podcast and then um
the comments of course were incredible
everyone's like dude
these are his own followers by the way
you're watching them live such fan
Behavior just admit you love Ethan
already
for the love of God pro please delete
you're in love with him bro if you watch
him live every day it's honestly so cute
number one fupa Trooper obsessed Ethan's
living room free like a hundred percent
of the comments were goofing on him
is literally family who watches every
live show yeah bro got his feet crossed
and kicked back watching a person's
podcast he swears he hates
just say you're a fan cute socks low so
quick with it obsessed much and it's
just it's so good it's all this
um and he erased it
and reposted the HD clip but yeah he was
trying to turn this into a thing he got
me in trouble and I think what happened
was he was celebrating because he think
he thought I was going to get another
strike he got super trashed and then
called into his friend's show and that's
when he made the grave mistake hit it
Zach
yo bro I met this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight
why would you say that dude even if it's
proved the vocalizing that is insane
he's forever
bar night mixed with what happened on
the episode that day was just the
perfect storm for Keem it was late
fortnite what huh would you say mix
mixed with what was said on stream
and bar night bar night the night before
Thanksgiving oh so he was in a festive
mood oh yeah yeah that's like the
biggest drinking night of the year well
according to him
okay before Thanksgiving what it might
be true no no it is it is is it the
biggest yeah it's like people like it
right behind New Year's yeah people
because everyone's back home like oh
okay it's usually like college kids I
feel like who are drinking but I know a
lot of families I think it's regular
where families get together on
Thanksgiving and Christmas and all these
like that and they all get drunk and I I
can't even imagine that because nobody
in my family drinks they do have
everyone getting trashed all day seems
kind of fun and cool but my family would
never do that uh we're just we don't
like drinking I guess does anyone's
family do that oh hell yeah
not the day before Thanksgiving that
sounds like alcohol alcoholic territory
but does it ever go sideways when you
get drunk with your whole family oh yeah
oh yeah but let's
that's really fun yeah
that's crazy well we're boring I think
because we just hang out eat and then
everyone goes home so there's I guess
there's kind of a nice bonding
experience just to get drunk talk about
how you want to [ __ ] high schoolers oh
wait that was keemstar
yo bro I've got this high school girl
that I was hot as [ __ ] tonight so like
when you have a reputation for going
after young girls and your girlfriend
current girlfriend has braces and just
graduated high school
to say that out to vocalize that on a
live stream is just wild bro
wild man
yeah everyone's saying it always goes
sideways uh the drinking with your
family oh yeah I'm drawn that's funny
I gotta try that someday during a
holiday just be like listen we're all
getting trash today just see what the
[ __ ] happens
I always wondered what it's like
um for people who get to drink or smoke
like with their family members it sounds
like it'd be so interesting
well yeah I mean my a lot of my family
smokes together like my sisters all into
that and my dad smokes a lot
but to drink I don't know I guess I've
gotten maybe drunk with them once or
twice at a restaurant when we're on
vacation I don't know
you smoked with my fan maybe yeah I did
it oh when was that my brothers after
your brother's wedding we were in the
year bushes or or whatever your garden
there you go back yeah
who was with my sister
I cannot confirm nor deny you can say
it's fine nobody in my family cares
everyone knows means legal got blues
yeah yeah
totally legal now it's not like Gary
sometimes I'll tell you one thing that
definitely doesn't happen when you get
smashed with your family is that you
don't end up talking about hot high
schoolers that doesn't happen at your
house dude I met a girl in high school
it was so [ __ ] hot all right tell me
which grade freshman
or senior
I know it shouldn't matter but let's
just break it down now what grade is she
on King
that makes sense yeah so he said that
but the whole stream was just a whole
lot uh minefield
of career-ending cringe so I want to I
just wanted to go over my favorite hits
I'm sure he thought this was buried and
nobody was going to talk about but I was
like please don't let me get banned
because on Monday I'm so looking forward
to watching this live stream
yeah but should we throw it to a vote
because you know I know everyone not
everyone loves this kind of thing and uh
people get a little bit like oh keemstar
sucks we all know let's do a vote I want
to know that the people are riding for
this do you want more highlights from
the cursed keemstar live stream
or do you want us to talk about the I
don't know whatever the [ __ ] else we got
and let me just say in my opinion I
think this is better than the 8 inch
stream I know it's a big claim but well
how could it yeah and the Aidan stream
was amazing but like when you say this
Zach go ahead
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight when you say
that that's that's just it doesn't get
oh yes that old people I love the family
that is that's a blowout 89 thank you
guys I needed that confirmation I feel
so good I feel so confident now 87
that's like a total blowout thank you
guys
thank you thank you thank you thank you
amen so nice happy happy holidays guys
how is that Paul everyone how'd you rate
that poll huh was that accurate do you
want more highlights from the curse
keemstar live stream yes or no seems
accurate to me no problem with me so
it's a good poll seems like people are
saying bad poll though God damn
I love you guys man all right and I try
it's okay Dan it's all right we'll get
it right
we got to recoup during that break just
try not to think about poles for a
little bit we'll figure it out sounds
like like uh acoustic version or
something oh cool
Dan is crying okay come on it's a good
pull down it was a good pull everyone
knows it was a good pull Dan don't worry
these clips will heal you they healed my
dick as soon as I watched the first one
and work again
immediate you're seeing you gotta you
listen to keemstar talk about high
schools you got an erection
here we go
I'm just kind of a gay friend that
probably wants to [ __ ] you like dead ass
okay so let's just get into it
this is intense cringe so but it's so
much fun so let's just get right into it
now this all took place over like a
couple hours uh live stream the stream
itself was several hours several hours
came in and out for within like two
hours
and also Keem this was sent to us so I
know you think I'm watching you 24 7.
don't blame me for this [ __ ] nah you
know yeah the fans are on this [ __ ] like
butter
and so we've cut it up to our favorite
moments and here we present you
keemstar running a dog over on Christmas
metaphorically
foreign
here it is a Christmas special a very
keemy special
I met a girl in high school that was so
[ __ ] hot oh look at the comment here
came that first clip you're gonna look
bad on H3 subreddit without the context
there you go what context
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight
yeah make sure yeah to prepare yourself
for this because oh okay
all right
all right here we go starting from the
top this one keemstar calls the host gay
and says he has friends at in Buffalo
who would [ __ ] him the host is a
straight man keemstar seems to be
expressing some repressed homosexuality
he seems to be interested in uh the host
here
um and often talks about his friend who
wants to have sex with him in quotes
let's hear shut up Edwin you like dudes
in your ass uh no I don't if I like
dudes I would put it in the ass
thank you Amen to that I got an idea
that's what's up I think
I got a gay friend that probably wants
to [ __ ] you like dead ass me
yeah yeah
yeah he'd love to [ __ ] you
wow his friend I don't know I'll [ __ ]
you up when you come to Buffalo Edwin
I'll hook you up
his friend of course we all know what he
means by that his friend
yes his friend in Buffalo he couldn't be
talking about is he his friend I've seen
this stick before yeah so I've got a
friend right the fact that I mean I
don't think he has friends is like the
big tip off there yeah so
who could he be talking yeah well I've
seen this act before this this is like
when I called him I always had his
friend Neil yeah exactly yeah I called
my Uncle on Thanksgiving I said my
friend really hurt his dick can you give
him some advice yeah we all know that
[ __ ]
yeah
there it is so that's that's a fun one
right there you got that queued up uh
Zach because these are going to be
useful really I got a gay friend that
probably wants to [ __ ] you yeah these
are just I mean this is Christmas these
sound bites do not get better happy
holidays everyone yes thank you I'm so
glad you're back Zach you couldn't have
come at a more time uh timely thank you
thank you I miss I missed I I honestly I
miss work yeah we missed you we did miss
you
uh here keemstar yells into an empty
room saying he is about to have a
threesome it's the the Echo and
emptiness of the room is resounding he's
clearly talking to nobody in the hopes
of looking cool here we go
um though says drunk him is my new
favorite team
um yeah you know
what you want oh my gosh
you know if you need a tender lady
that's fine too Kim don't worry about it
a lady you mean you're ladies
plural oh you oh you oh oh [ __ ] so
and you come and hang out with the boys
what you want what what were we talking
about
yeah keemstar's having a win uh there's
a whole gaddle of women there foaming at
the mouth to sleep with Kingdom there's
so many women here silent dead silent
they're just out of frame yeah just all
of the naked women they're just out of
friends
you listen to The Emptiness when he says
that that room um like there's a
resounding emptiness oh it says drunk
him as my new favorite team
um yeah you know
I am ready for that I'm on a Discord
he's yelling at the wall
there is nobody there there's nobody
there I mean is there a private all
girls high school in Buffalo
we could maybe figure that out on Google
Maps if there's one nearby just for uh
fact checking oh man Pierce painful
[Laughter]
I am beaming this is so much fun you
guys yeah the echo is deafening exactly
plural I'm just so happy to be here I'm
so happy to be here and share this
Monday with you guys I know it is a
Christmas miracle keep the music going
please Zach let's keep the festivities
it's funny all the comments too are
[ __ ] on him and being like Ethan's
gonna have a field day with this a lot
of the comments if you notice are like
dude you're not gonna remember this or
they're like do you want to [ __ ] this
guy
[Music]
um
came projecting his pedophilia while
drunk oh boy yeah Keem do you think he's
cute Kane will not remember this
tomorrow
yeah this is wild and what's crazy is
that
this guy's so cucked for Keem that he
actually either removed it or made it
members only instead of keeping it
public which like this is Banger content
bro why wouldn't you want to keep this
public because keemstar obviously begged
you and said yo you need to take that
down
and I don't know man
well we got it so I don't [ __ ] care
just saying I think you're being too
harsh you think so yeah everybody knows
the Thanksgiving Eve is the biggest
drinking day of the year everybody knows
that okay
yeah and who who who amongst us has not
gotten wasted on Thanksgiving Eve and
confessed to
being attracted to high school girls
okay well we're a show of hands how many
people confess to wanting to uh [ __ ] uh
high school girls on Thanksgiving yeah
anyone show hands hands
well I mean I haven't personally but I I
thought I thought you yeah and I'll hook
you up
with some beef jerky
yeah we kid the keemstar he's a good guy
um
keemstar is making fun of a girl who has
a handicap
who joins the call she joins the stream
and she actually I guess has some kind
of handicap I'm not super familiar with
her situation but here it is this is
fantastic
[ __ ]
yeah maybe during the clip you can turn
it off in case or I don't know
oh it's kind of a Vibe yeah okay maybe
it's real low yeah I'll bet it you know
what keep the Vibes up okay let's get
into this morning yeah Christmas morning
where these are all different presents
so many presents this year it's been
really a beautiful year he didn't uh
like that I said it was so [ __ ] up I
might make piece of Claire tonight that
[ __ ] British yo what up
calling
wait Claire are you gonna call in is
that what you said is what you said yeah
Claire should call in get that dumb in
here so we can talk about our uh our our
and and and what is the term industry
uh
our DNA history ancestry bro what did he
say hold on do you have that sound bited
Zach uh I think I have the DNA history
one the Artistry our DNA history
uh and what is the term industry
Dentistry interest rate I think he's
missing a few letters
uh oh he says he's dyslexic though so
let's go let's be fair you know yeah
let's not make fun of them for not being
able to pronounce stuff man and who am I
he's disabled and who am I to judge
let's not even you know what I mean true
come on that's not the big deal here our
DNA history what is that term
understanding there you go bad ancestry
yeah all right Clara is that girl that
girl came from some [ __ ] stupid
people
Hey listen um she's actually handicapped
that makes sense that makes sense that
makes sense uh Kim she's a private
person I don't know if you can say that
there's private the reason why I bully
her is because I [ __ ] I love that
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow yeah that's pretty and what's
fascinating too
is that we're really getting like a
unique almost uh unrefined pure look
into keemstar's psyche and this is a
reoccurring theme the way he talks about
women the way he talks about people with
disabilities
um it's really interesting it's really
interesting our
DNA history what is that term
ancestry
I believe it is you're thinking of so
Keem says a few drinks in and the
handicapped girl would want to hook up
with him later on they're talking here
it is uh Clara I believe her name was
the conversation why you don't like me
do
you oh no honey come on please the
reason why I don't like you is because
you're a dumb
kind of ugly too I did see you on
FaceTime watch what the [ __ ]
I did it yeah I know is I well I think
you're kind of ugly but I also think I
can see how people think you're
attractive but I don't fight you're
attractive no no stop it bro couple
drinks in like you're done like please
like you'd be an easy level what are you
saying she would be loose you're
projecting wait so uh Clara would you be
looser if you had a few drinks in you
no I wouldn't I think Kim would be
towards me if I was in real life that
was kind of the implication I do see
that like [ __ ] you know I kind of like
agree with her in a sense but also like
only because like I would try to conquer
something right it's like a like a power
move type of thing right yeah
instinctual man thing
yeah
not because I was like naturally
attractive to Clara but just because
like a power move type of thing yeah
there you go a really interesting
Glimpse and it came upstairs mine
he confesses in a moment of uh
[Applause]
moment of frankness that he would sleep
with her just because he wanted to
feel like a real man apparently we gotta
get her a little drunk first yeah my
plan is to get you drunk then take
advantage of you I have no interest in
you by the way
I think this is I think this is what a
lot of women are afraid men are like
right like this is this is the man that
women fear
and yet here he is he's coming out and
saying it
but all men are not like that I just
want to I want you want to um caution
you guys that men are not all like that
probably a lot are I'll be honest
but we're not all just trying to uh have
sex to feel good about ourselves which I
think is what he's essentially admitting
to
the dirty Dom uh he the drink he's on is
the dirty Dom uh Martini actually
inspired by uh
another YouTuber
that girl that girl came from some
[ __ ] stupid people
I'll say this at least she knows who she
came from
I'm just gonna throw that out there
because he said it about her so I'm just
gonna defend her you know they might be
dumb but at least they exist [ __ ]
and the love of parents goes a long way
yes uh of course of course of course an
up next Keem yells to Brantley is that
her name Brantley or Brantley Brian
Brent wait it is Brandt or Brent or
Brent
Brantley Brantley here he is to Brantley
to bring him a jewel baby
need a jewel
me and her are the only one dancing in
the [ __ ] bar you know wow baby I need
a I need a jewel pod
do you know what it's giving me
um Step or or Wedding Crashers when Will
Ferrell screams mom lasagna
look crazy her the only one dancing in
the [ __ ] bar you know wow baby I need
a I need a jewel pod
you got that one Zach I need it
I love that baby don't threesomes right
now please
I need a jewel pod
so good
actually I skipped one he came asked if
host broke up with his ex because he's
gay he is obsessed with the sexuality of
the host here
and I'm not sure why uh maybe it's for
his friend in Buffalo who'd be very
excited to have sex with him wait man
you know I mean I'm glad you're happy
with yours and yeah
why did you all break up because your
boyfriend came over
uh long distance
hmm
didn't laugh at that one unfortunately
uh sorry didn't work out for you though
buddy I'm sure his friend in Buffalo
would love to see you I got a gay friend
that probably wants to [ __ ] you like
dead ass yeah and that's a that's it's
nice to feel desired um
I need a jewel pod
the sound bite we might have in this
late entry Sound by competition finally
oh yeah I mean from behind victory yeah
yeah yeah Dark Horse material here wow
a work a world cup of Our Own
um up next keemstar tells a story
about how he was hanging out with
Leonardo the cat Caprio on the food
chain this is the best one and what is
potentially the most unbelievable story
I've ever heard and when I say
unbelievable I mean he's obviously lying
and everybody knows that but he
continues to say it it I think he thinks
that he's too drunk to think that people
don't know he's lying he's scared me
about threesomes he's telling he's
hanging out with Lino DiCaprio it's
really something this story is great
yeah now
um let's let's go ahead and listen here
um
to keemstar Bro one time I was in a club
and I'm like [ __ ] hit my Jewel thank
you baby I love you
um I'm hitting my jewelry fuel
delivery's here in the club
what jewel delivery arrived thank you
baby Julie thank you Joel please now
take now all you and all the ladies go
put on your clothes all 40 of you naked
naked women
get back to the high school gymnasium
please skip school tomorrow no it's too
hot in here there's too many bodies work
with me
I ripped my dick the other day work with
me I need a break I'm drunk all right
here we go and uh bartender comes over
it gives me a nice shot of [ __ ]
Jagger I had a jagger bomb at this club
all right I'm sitting there with like
[ __ ] cool
um
cheers him we do the shot I'm doing a
Jager Bomb I don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing
and uh it was Leonardo DiCaprio
so so he's at a club
he's getting a Jaeger shot somebody
cheers him from the side just randomly
it throws a cheers to him
who was that man
Leonardo DiCaprio
which is funny because he's like the
most private dude in like the whole
world like he doesn't leave the house
without like hoodies and giant Shades
there's no [ __ ] shot I don't do I
need to explain it
come on
I think Amy's right he he speculated
that like
this this meme just popped into his mind
and he's like how can I make this about
me absolutely please find Leo DiCaprio
had his back turned it was like
Leonardo was in a uh tuxedo yeah which
cheerings me with a champagne glass he
was so drunk he's just thinking The
Great Gatsby you have to you have to say
it like how Keem says it because he says
a very specific way Leonardo DiCaprio
that's awesome
wait is Jager Bomb a type of drink that
says something about somebody I don't
I'm not it's pretty
I don't want to insult anybody that's a
fan of uh Jagermeister but
it's to me it's associated with I hate
to say it with but with high schoolers
getting drunk that's when I drink it yes
exactly like it I mean I'm sure some
people do enjoy Jaeger B I don't think I
had any Jaeger since since high school
that's what I'm saying it's like a Jager
Bomb is like but I like it so I'm not
I'm not like hating on it it's an
interesting drink I'm not this high
school girl that I was hot as [ __ ]
tonight yeah she probably wants a Jager
Bomb
I need a jewel pod smart
anyway he continues so he's at the bar
cheerings with Leonardo DiCaprio uh how
could this story get any better
and um he like ice me up I eye him up
right I'm with some [ __ ] Leonardo wait
hold on I'm sorry Leonardo's eyeing him
up like look at this guy this guy is fly
as hell boy I need to learn I need to
get to know this dude yo those are those
ripped shorts dude yo Leonardo was also
wearing Jordans he'd dabbed me up
he complimented my bandana we're both
into teenage girls we
he actually does go there a little bit
let me go back a little bit I don't
wanna I don't want to interrupt this is
too good yeah by eye him up right I'm
with some [ __ ] like I'm cheating right
like I'm being a scumbag and I got some
like [ __ ]
20-something year old girl like on my
arm or whatever cool and she filled me
up uh [ __ ] leaner or DiCaprio's got
some young [ __ ] with him and [ __ ]
naturally and then uh two chains is
playing in the club right and I'm like
[ __ ] bumping and like these two
chains like album right it sounds like
like uh acoustic version or some [ __ ]
like it doesn't make sense
like that there's two chains here he
goes yay right there and so the people
so wait it was Leo it was Leo who told
him yeah it's two chains he's right
there yeah he's doing an acoustic set at
the club
are you sure you know it sounds like a
weird dream like it sounds you know be
like whoa that was weird I was at the
bar with Leo and 2 Chainz was doing an
acoustic set it sounds like he's trying
to impress a bunch of high schoolers
like uh Matthew McConaughey's character
from days and Confused like Waterson
he's like that's what I love about high
school girls like this happened man I
saw him like he's trying to be like that
well hold on these guys were seen
partying in 2013 that's a long time ago
a VMA after party I don't think keemstar
would have been out of VMA after party
in 2013 I don't think so
oh God I love this we were with our
young [ __ ] and he was looking at me I
was cheating I was cheating on my other
[ __ ]
is he really becoming a tater tot like
keemstar you're 40 bro you're way too
you can't be doing this I'm disabled
woman I'm disabled
yes yes yeah I know you're dyslexic
because I'm not gonna make fun of you
for that I also have problems
not even problems let's just call them
special features you know I mean I want
to be sensitive
that's special people listen you know
it's not a problem it's a special
feature
you know some perks like when you're
playing a video game there's pluses and
minuses uh-huh right it's a special
feature yeah you got them in Max
uh yeah so by the way does 2 Chain play
acoustic sets if you Google that does
anything come up
no it doesn't make any oh what would
that even mean I don't know
I've seen rappers do like Acoustics I
mean acapella I guess like without
backing although that wouldn't be
happening at a club like ever wait do
you see anything Olivia on Two Chains
dude MTV Unplugged what are you talking
about yeah maybe when he went by titty
boy let me look titty boy he used to go
by titty boy yeah
like like uh acoustic version or
something acoustic sense it doesn't
really but
okay if Leonardo says it's happening
it's happening this girl that I'm
[ __ ] with at the time this like a
couple years ago
and um they pull us up and we go behind
stage and we're right next to [ __ ]
two chains Two Chains is smoking a
[ __ ] blood sing this brand new song
like live in this [ __ ] club I just
cheers with Leonardo DiCaprio right
this is the wildest [ __ ] ever sure and
I'm seeing like [ __ ] like straight A
like [ __ ] celebrities and whatnot in
this club in LA
it was it was probably like the coolest
[ __ ] experience ever to be honest
yeah is it possible he thought this
happened he was like so blackout drunk
he like in his mind he's just imagining
all this it's just like a small band
serenading in the corner and he's just
having like this intense
alcohol induced psychosis I think he's
told this lie to so many young girls for
so long that he started to believe it he
forgot it was a [ __ ] story he's just
used to telling it because he never gets
any pushback I'm sure he's like he went
one time I don't know if we don't know
the crap girl and they're like oh [ __ ]
dope he was like tell me more yeah so uh
two changes playing acoustic it was a
two tank uh cover band and then they
invited me backstage for some reason
and then and then we were drinking and
smoking blunts
let's see two chains well let's fact
check this two chains does appear to he
said it was a couple years ago that'd be
like 2020.
right not 2012 so I'll keep Two Chains
apparently formed at a club in LA in
2012.
uh but it was it acoustic I don't think
I think I think his definition of
acoustic doesn't necessarily mean
acoustic we're trying this don't you
can't say I'm not giving you the benefit
I'm trying to fact check you bro I'm
talking to keemstar yeah yeah I'm trying
my best to be a as good faith on this as
possible but it looks to me that the
last time two chains were formed in a
club in L.A
was 2012. Big Sean brought him out in
2021 at a club he was performing at Big
Sean
so he may have been there with Leonardo
DiCaprio definitely he may have been
there then maybe that's what he saw I
mean he may have so he so he why didn't
he mention Big Sean was there that would
be cool the detail that he forgot thank
you yeah big fan
hmm I'm jealous that's a cool story
that's just what happens in La man Chad
says does he just mean live
I think that I I think that that's
actually what that means yeah I think
it's just funny that he said acoustic
yeah he just means like it wasn't being
played by a DJ it was he was actually
there hey play the sound bites Zach
let's analyze it like like uh acoustic
version or some [ __ ] like it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense he says
it's not just live it's a total remix an
acoustic version
it makes sense it doesn't make sense for
it to not make sense it must be very
different than what two change usually
does
doesn't make sense
well that's quite a story kid uh
keemstar goes on to talk about the first
time he saw Alyssa violet
wait somebody just said this is the same
story he told banks on their podcast but
in this version of the story he was
there with banks
yeah yeah no in this one he says I was
there with banks so why would he have
been telling Banks the same story well
I'm saying we started to question if
this really happened let's reach out to
Banks and say yo were you ever at a club
with keemstar with Leonardo DiCaprio and
two chains
why the [ __ ] you lying
why you lying oh my God why are you
[ __ ] loud Zach what happened
hit the wrong one oh no
oh wait I'll wait for it why the [ __ ]
you lying
[Music]
stop [ __ ] lying
love that
okay well that was good that was good uh
I'm drunk uh up next he talks about the
first time he saw Alissa violet
in 2017 she was 21 and he was 35 at the
time yeah and that's that's when they
dated we don't know for sure if that was
the year but they only dated for like
two years ago that's our best guess give
or take 21.
that is such a diverse I don't know how
that soundbot became so useful it's
crazy but nice special number so here's
keemstar 35 talking about the first time
he saw Alissa Violet 21 were just
estimating the ages there was this small
bit somebody in the chat said Alyssa
Violet is so pretty there was this
moment where we were waiting to go out
to a club or something and Alyssa Violet
had to get ready and Alyssa Violet came
down the stairs and I literally said in
front of banks who is his girlfriend
right I literally said oh my [ __ ] god
and ricegum
because she dressed the [ __ ] nine and
like walked down the stairs it was like
one of those moments like I don't know
like when a girl is going to prom or
something like think of that scenario in
a movie where the girls like getting
ready to go somewhere and she comes down
the stairs it was like one of those
moments yeah that girl is Drop Dead
[ __ ] gorgeous
and when she puts it on she puts it on
it's [ __ ] stupid
uh
speechless
literally speechless how do you follow
that up I mean she's 20. once you're not
that young but um
it's not about her age at the time it's
where his mind goes but he's literally
from prom yeah white dude get out of
high school it's like how many yeah stop
stop bro it's time to move past High
School you're 40 bro
40.
yeah so Alyssa Violet if you are
watching
uh keemstar you you thought you were the
Bell you were the prom queen he's
interested hey Alyssa Violet you might
be if you're lucky and play your card
right you might be able to be a third uh
to
Brantley and Keem
you might be able to retrieve him jewels
uh if you play your cards right
so keem's tweet the caption was uh
Ethan Klein hates his fans
I'm having so much fun right now wait
what what he's tweeted about me is that
what you're talking about yeah pulled up
I I personally I think it's he's trying
to ruin Christmas for us right now I
think we should watch it at the end
let's watch this and then we'll look at
what keemstar is saying he will not ruin
this Christmas he's being a grandchild
you're not making this from us game just
enjoy the show just watch don't be a
grinch don't be mixed Scrooge you know
what I mean
this is a Christmas miracle let's just
and you know what be visited by the
ghosts of Christmas past present and
future and just you know come out the
other side like a beautiful uh
uh humanistic uh was it uh Ebenezer
Ebenezer yes Ebenezer thank you baby I
love you I'll call you Ebenezer for the
remainder of the segment
ever these Ebenezer Deez Nuts I don't
know does that work it's Ebenezer yeah
these nuts
you cut the Buffalo and I'll hook you up
thanks bro all right uh Brantley
talks about how she Grooms everybody
wait why that's no this is what team had
a little slip I think right here okay
let's hear it out let's hear him out you
know
I'm here I'm I'm being fair keemstar I
don't know how you're gonna say I'm not
being totally fair I literally just fact
checked I tried my best to find out
Leonardo DiCaprio 2 change thing bro it
was in 21 21 and maybe you were there
with Big Sean somebody said uh somebody
said he claims that we're misleading his
fans maybe we should reply to his tweet
from the podcast account with a link to
the stream and his fans can come and
check out for themselves come judge for
yourself yeah if you want I'm surprised
he hasn't blocked the podcast yeah I
want to do that Bella Simmons another
account to see this guy it's not even
worth interacting with them yeah
uh by the way he did go of his way and
like preemptively block you didn't he
Olivia that's kind of interesting I
thought that was funny he did while I
was at school
he blocked me too he blocked all you
guys yeah he blocked and Brantley
blocked me I didn't say I've never said
one word I like Brantley I got nothing
bad to say about her yeah she's cool uh
Bella Simmons donated 100 and said love
you all have fun and then went on to
donate 50 gifted memberships oh my God
Belle you're so much Legend dude Bella
able to get Bella's awesome I love her
thank you so much yeah and we got and
according to recording that's what live
is all about that's right that's the
only reason we do it that's why we're
here
so keemstar actually blocked my A3 out
of context
he's thorough you probably you probably
troll applied on that account at some
point never right no you never
interacted with them no I didn't okay
well then that's fine
oh this is so funny I'm not blocked oh
[ __ ] you better uh you forgot Zach came
started hey right here buddy at what
you're at handle so he knows at Zach The
Sound Lab there it is if do you need me
to spell that for you no no no don't you
check it out at uh yeah okay
uh January um 17th at uh January 6 live
at the Capitol
yeah live at the Capitol steps January
6th Insurrection anniversary keemstar
was there I heard oh wait no I didn't
hear sorry I may have been confused
I heard Two Chains was there with
Leonardo DiCaprio
yeah he was having a he I heard him say
he was having a uh a uh what do you call
it when you party out of the back of
your truck tailgate tailgate with
Leonardo DiCaprio two chains of Big Sean
yeah he's having a Kiki with Leo yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was fun lucky guy
uh here he is uh let's see where this
goes well it's working it's working so
what I'm getting groomed this is so
ridiculous she Grooms everyone here's
the thing
was that out of context let's be fair
was that out of content okay
so Brantley fell
and he's makes a big deal out of oh
Brantley fell Brantley fell them she's
more drunk than I am and then Bradley's
like no no Edward and say he's more
drunk you know you love me don't say
it's me and then keems like that's not
fair she's she's using you she's
grooming you and then he's like yeah I
feel groomed he's like yeah she Grooms
everyone okay so perhaps a Freudian slip
of sorts correct but yes he wasn't
oh this is fun we're having too much fun
here I actually need to pee really bad
I'm so sorry I can't hold it
um hold that thought just
just do it on the floor Let It Go
well it yeah okay this is the biggest
buckets
pay some almonds to the quartering he
gave you a compliment and I'll give him
right back yeah piss on the drain uh
what about a bucket we don't have a
drain uh can you get me a big bucket
please leave it no I'm just kidding I'm
gonna go pee I'll be right back
boring yo somebody just said my trading
cards just arrived oh oh yeah let's go
those are already coming in
shout out Jasmine thanks for ordering
did you get the golden ticket
Jasmine
I guess get back to me
I cannot believe how much fun I'm having
watching this today almost spit out my
water at work
we're having fun too yeah we have fun
doing with folks oh yeah
Christmas came early like I said I can't
say it enough
somebody I saw
um actually confirmed
that AB or that uh Keem was at that club
I was at the club with two chains and
Leo pretty sure a b was there too he
saved someone from choking in the
bathroom
I I didn't want to say it every time I
tell one of these stories No One
Believes Me so yeah
I was there though
hell yeah well this is a great episode
to come back to I just want to say that
I'm having a lot of fun as well we
missed you Zach on and off the show you
bring a certain Vibe and it's not the
same without you appreciate that thank
you and it does feel quiet without you
a lot less walking behind Ian going on
yeah I bet he loves that
it's
true
my grandma cooked my sister a steak for
Thanksgiving because she doesn't like
ham or turkey I called her Zack all
night yeah actually
we weren't going to talk about it but
since it just came up
Zach was getting some hate on the
subreddit for a supposedly burnt looking
steak and
um I feel like we should correct the
record here a little bit it wasn't a
steak it was a pot roast it was a four
pound roast and it was very delicious
and you can you know make fun of it you
can call it what you want I don't care
it tasted good so you know [ __ ] yourself
yeah
um about they said that you were
laughing at every video oh yeah I saw
that
they said that you cheated the whole
game what are your thoughts about that I
mean you all were sitting around me not
once did any of you think that I was
laughing that's the game that's the game
yeah you got hate for laughing I got
hate for not left I didn't laugh here's
the thing the rules were very explicitly
spelled out at the beginning if you make
a peep yeah audible noise that's
immediate you're done I was I was silent
Lena just tried to call me
just to do an aside here a lot I was
reading the comments on the you laugh
you lose lots of people were accusing
Dan of shenanigans but listen it's not
Dan's fault it's Ian and Sam were
judging so they made the call and we got
us we have to respect that
just say though anyway let's let's keep
on track here sorry thank you guys for
sticking around
yeah so we were going on
um Brantley continues to make fun of
keemstar for being 40 and not
understanding
women
that's well Kim's are not understanding
women that's so surprised let's hear it
it's your your fault that you haven't
learned it's your fault that you haven't
learned
how are you 40 you're 40 right you 40
year old ass you 40 and you don't know
how women act you don't know your ins
and outs I know what women want I say
this this is my move okay if I really do
like a female which I there's I'm really
picky I'm really picky but if I know a
girl I'll walk up to her I say yo
I just want to let you know you're so
gorgeous you look so beautiful and you
caught my eye and I know you saw me
looking at you
I want you I want to let you know the
ass is nice
I'll let them know that and that's the
move that's interesting wow yeah and
they're like young lady why aren't you
in school
it's one o'clock it's fifth period right
now that only works for women to women
exactly she's got a cheat code she's a
woman she's not threatening there's no
way we're threatening we could be like
rapists or something well exactly yeah
we could not not me we could be rapists
they're Killers not me by the way I just
want to get this girl who's uh mentally
disabled drunk and have a suit
we're not rapists though all of that
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my God
how do you even talk like that that's
crazy
yeah this combo I was telling uh
I think it was me I felt like this
conversation was from like 1990 or some
[ __ ] the way they're saying [ __ ] and
calling everything gay I was like holy
smokes man
but there you go I think that was I mean
keemstar has a case of Arrested
Development and I think he stopped
developing
in the 90s
so
I've explained it
as well
you had a girlfriend
well
for you okay okay okay okay Bradley get
the [ __ ] out of here
ah Bradley just fell braley's drunker
than me Riley fell in my room yo Mark
this Mark this down somebody record this
now she's twerking on me I'm trying to
cover her fall she stumbled in my room
she's way drunker than me I don't care
that twerk doesn't count that's worked
this account she's twerking I don't want
to hear [ __ ] she's working to try to
cover up the fact that she fell over
she's way transferred that is that is
that is
what else are you supposed to do when
you follow
yeah I don't know what that is but uh
put your [ __ ] clothes on I already
where's all the other girls I just heard
Brantley
she does voices I thought there was like
three other naked girls there yeah yeah
they left they were it was time for them
it was their bedtime it's Pastor curfew
their parents would notice if they're
gone past date
they snuck back in their window
or they climbed out of a window mm-hmm
that makes sense yeah
okay now here we go uh obviously this is
the Great Clip that we've been talking
about where he says he just saw a hot
ass High School no this is basically the
crown jewel in the evening here so let's
enjoy Punk okay welcome yo this is right
when he calls huh Thanksgiving right
it's the biggest trick in the year how
the [ __ ] are you not drunk
yeah I love you too Ally [ __ ] I
guarantee you got some prime puss all
right
dude wait are you trying to say that
Ellie doesn't have pride plus [ __ ] you
actually right now for that [ __ ] that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] how dare you say
Ellie doesn't have pride pause I want to
ask you uh the ladies in the room this
Prime puss he seems to think that's a
high compliment you guys like Prime puss
do you like that if a man said that to
you it'll be good that'd be you would be
a good pickup line
I say red flags oh you don't like the
prime Place what's up girl I bet you got
some prime the first thing
no no
what's up Prime I take like a hey
is good I take those like hi yeah hi
hello what's your name like stuff like
that okay well you're not at home so I'm
not sure I could trust you right does
that come after the hay or yeah where do
we fit from well if that's later in the
relationship if you've had relations and
it goes you've got some so like 10
minutes
you're so right I do yeah yeah yeah
we're talking five ten minutes but he's
saying that about a girl he seems to be
acquainted with there's not you know
what I mean they're disabled
go on oh that's it
I thought there'd be more
so drunk yo bro I'm at this high school
girl that I was hot as [ __ ] tonight what
what
shut the [ __ ] up bye guys good night you
wanna you wanna hear everybody's trying
to save his ass it's almost like he said
bomb
that's like you know there's a parallel
there I think because he's making fun of
me he goes look how all the crews just
wanted you just said a bomb joke my
friend
except about you know [ __ ]
kids
I need a jewel pod
is it a freshman you know what I mean
the story or not like I don't give a
[ __ ] I won't tell you the story so at
this point
he pivots and says you guys I'll play it
and then you guys tell me what you think
okay if you're not worthy of it remember
go ahead right
we're good
tell the story
okay 2007. I'm downtown I'm in the clubs
this girl cook right I'm not gonna say
any more than cookies The Only Name I'm
gonna give you there's a full name but
I'm just gonna give a cook cook is
working the clothes one of those girls
with a full name
and cl cook
is the like you know when you go to the
nightclub and there's hot ass [ __ ]
and like leather and [ __ ] you know what
I mean like they're the dancers the the
whatever right like cook it's not only
hot it's not only a [ __ ] tent but she
went to school with me like I know that
[ __ ] right type of [ __ ]
I see her tonight she's still looking
good [ __ ] she's making move on
brantley's brantley's making moves on
her she's making move on me bro I'm
telling you this girl's still [ __ ]
got it bro okay
to clarify this is a girl you knew from
high school from high school okay yeah
she probably okay I'm gonna say she
probably like 36. she's still got it
okay now let's go back to the beginning
of this before Brantley was like
punching him in the arm and telling him
what the [ __ ] did you say yeah now
keemstar
has never complemented anyone over the
age of like 25 in fact he was even on
Twitter saying
if you remember 911 I don't yeah posting
like random pictures of like 33 year old
women or something did me really yeah no
he posted straight up pictures of people
and said like you number the 911 thing
yeah he said if you remember 911 yeah I
think you remember yeah I'm not
interested I have it
yeah so um
let's go back to the beginning here and
then see if this is plausible the way he
tried to recover you try to say that I
only just have pride plus [ __ ] you wagon
cancel that one right now for that [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] how dare you
say okay before we Ellie you have prime
plus geez let me just calm down Elias
Prime pose calm down dude
here's his tweet by the way before he
talks about how hot this 36 year old was
you guys keep telling me to date some of
my own age I Googled a 39 year old woman
I will not be listening to any guys if
you remember where you were on 9 11 I'm
not interested and then he put these
random women on blast by the way was it
one of them like a missing person I
think several of them like there was
like because he just pulled it from
Google Images they were all from like
articles of like missing persons one of
them may have been slain too yeah and
like murder victims and stuff isn't that
awesome to like pull up a picture of a
woman who's like absolutely tragically
her life was cut short by some piece of
[ __ ] X and he's like this woman is not
only deadly do it I'm over the [ __ ]
Hill yeah you know she if she was alive
she'd be like I'd rather get killed
again from my ex-boyfriend than [ __ ]
spend a minute with that guy
Sheriff Office still searching for 39
year old missing Alton woman so
oops got him I guess got him
yes so before we get too deep
okay can we get a Joe pod and then we'll
continue
yes so now that we know his thoughts on
uh women in their 30s all right pause I
didn't know you knew you were so drunk
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight what what okay
dude he met a high school girl that is
hot as [ __ ] today
is there really any way to spin that
also the story itself as he describes
it's not that interesting goes oh I saw
a girl from high school who's hot like
what kind of story is it still hot she's
still hot she's a 10. maybe it is a big
story for him because and giving Kim
sort of benefited out he hasn't been
attracted to someone that old before
and yeah yeah it is like a revelatory
moment so it's like a first for him so
maybe that is possible the thing is he
remembers what she looks like in high
school so he can kinda is that fantasy
a 10 year old fan right away 10 year old
fan that's
no come on
um
so they yell at him
you want to hear the story or not like I
don't give a [ __ ] right now he's trying
to think what the [ __ ] am I gonna say
because when has keemstar ever been like
I need do you guys want to hear me talk
or not I mean he just talks he spits he
spews non-stop but right now he's
pausing for time he's trying to think
what the [ __ ] to say about it keemstar
shut up if you're not worthy of it
you're not remember go ahead like
nobody's even saying anything weird like
they want it you know what I mean he's
just talking you know we're good
they say no they say I don't want to
hear the story
all right well tell the story
okay 2007. I'm downtown I'm in the club
yeah the story doesn't make sense he
says in 2007 seven yeah
he saw a girl at the club who was hot
he's downtown he's at the club downtown
Buffalo Leonardo DiCaprio's there we're
stuck we're talking about Buffalo 10
right now two changes not real high
quality he comes out
Kanye West is in the back this is a
better setup than Lord of the Rings
Gimli from Lord of the Rings he's there
he hands me his ax everyone starts
clapping
I'm the ring bearer now
Brantley is Sam we venture to Mount Doom
somebody says if she's 36 and he's 40
that's a freshman plus senior that's a
good point so she was a freshman
when he was in high I mean if he's
really talking about adults like who
cares but well he he says in high school
she was hot as [ __ ] oh but he um oh wait
we're splitting I mean yeah I get what
you're saying it was a chat I thought it
was interesting acoustic version
makes sense
yeah so anyway that's a good one and
yeah so let's see
this girl cook right I'm not gonna say
any more than cook is the only name I'm
gonna give you there's a full name but
I'm just gonna give a cook yeah so let's
do a poll do you and again I just want
to do the benefit of the doubt here I'm
trying to present all sides to be fair
this is fair and accurate reporting
[Music]
I am uh yeah do you guys believe
keemstar was talking about
a high school girl that he thought was
cute
or two high school or
or
a 36 year old that
36 year old that he knew in high school
who he saw he saw in 2017. yeah way too
long for the poll do you guys believe
keemstar was talking about a high school
girl he thought was cute or a 36 year
old yeah that's fine yeah is that a bad
poll though that was hot as [ __ ] tonight
is that a bad pull maybe it's fine
wait Zach you play One More Time yo bro
I'm at this high school girl then I met
I met yeah I met tonight
I met tonight I met tonight this girl
I've known for 20 years you wouldn't say
if you're like yo I met this girl I know
why would you say High School
if you live in the same a girl I met
if you're talking about an old friend
you say I met a girl I used to I ran
into somebody yeah I knew in high school
tonight
yeah so I voted high school girl
personally after considering all the
evidence and just what I understand and
considering both perspectives clearly
keemstar
had uh a follow-up story
but I personally believe and it's my
opinion
that keemstar was talking about a high
school girl who's currently in high
school who was hot
then he got embarrassed and changed the
story to try to cover up that's my faith
and belief based on my opinion of the
circumstances there and it seems ninety
percent of you uh agree
ten percent uh I think well there you go
see I mean clearly we've we've put for
people saying it's a good pull now great
pull the pull is the bomb people are
saying yes so clearly we've put together
a fair and balanced pull if ten percent
are saying they believe him I mean
they're out there right
yeah and I was seeing them in the chat I
mean I think
I I saw somebody say they thought maybe
these were two different stories so I
mean he's very drunk it's kind of hard
to follow what he's talking about right
maybe he stands some skepticism here
yeah and I'll hook you up he may not
even know what he was saying he mixed up
stories because and the truth of the
matter is even if
he's 100 telling the truth and it wasn't
a high school girl still a great sound
bite We're Not Gonna not play it so yeah
this high school girl that was hot as
Fox tonight I mean that's just funny the
gift is still here we're a comedy show
and that's just funny you know what I
mean so there's that somebody said 2007
was the year she was born
well let me do the math it's a little
tight but yes you could be in high
school that's 50 that'd be 15 right yeah
yeah that might actually add up
oh man what is DP I think I think about
this let's see
3200 DPI
he's calm
let's let's crank it you wanna crank it
let's see yeah there we go 8200 DPI whoa
I'm down dude that's a prime putt eight
thousand that dude just saw some prime
prime DPA
18 MIP Prime DPA you reach out to him
Olivia
yeah I did make a note too good thank
you I got we got to get them
so that was good he continues on like I
said there's a lot guys this is a
bonanza came continue excuse me I'm
sorry my DPI is way too high and my
mouse is unusable now keep it all the
way up go ahead I'm gonna have to turn
it down go ahead go ahead
800 DPI 800 IPA back down to a nice
800.50 girl that's some prime plus oh
thank you that dick [ __ ] in it yeah
there you go man thank you to Bella
Simmons for another 50. no another so
cool that's 100 gifts oh and by the way
speaking of which
tomorrow is Ethan's live podcast
remember so thank you to all members
we'll be having another fun live episode
tomorrow I thought it was free
yeah well it is free but you have to be
a member it's not my premium speech it's
premium speech it's premium speech
what did you want me to finish didn't I
finish it uh Abe
there's still an ending where he he
tries to clarify it's
oh [ __ ] you're right okay well let's
you're right it's important to finish it
all
just give the full context if it was
Brantley even alive in 2007 she's older
than 15 so yeah yeah I'm barely she was
paralyzed she was my son's age right
he's very young for the record it's only
three
[ __ ] 10 but she went to school with
me like okay
to clarify this is a girl you knew from
high school from high school okay okay
probably like 36. she still got it she
has like three kids she got three kids
she still got it still okay he's lying
he goes now I'm convinced because
there's no there's no Universe where
he's like she's got three cribs she's 36
she's a 10. but also he was like this
mother of three was flirting with me and
Brantley yeah in downtown Buffalo
oh my God
stop [ __ ] lying yeah there's no
Universe where keemstar says that
well we're the if you remember 911 I
don't want to talk to you well why don't
you ask um Barack Obama I heard he was
there that evening you can corroborate
and [ __ ] too
[Music]
what a relief you phrase that poorly
yeah yeah what do you mean
at first it sounded way worse you
started off saying girl from a hot high
school girl or something yeah
yeah when I was in high school
[ __ ] yeah
are you a [ __ ] pedophile like get the
[ __ ] out of there you said it bro
uh
uh I'm sorry dude but that is very hard
to believe nice try though he did a
night he did honestly Valiant effort
if he was covering up that was pretty
well played I think but in the Electric
Slide you know what I'm gonna go against
the grain here I'm gonna say he's
telling the absolute truth wow he did
see a girl he he reconnected with from
high school and he also saw a high
schooler currently in high school that
he thinks is hot as [ __ ] ah you think he
just swerved into a into a separate
story two separate people that two
distinct events okay so here we have a
diversity of of ideas
but he definitely thinks the high
schooler is hot oh yeah well not that
diverse
love you believe him right just say just
say because here let me type you
something
let me feed you what to say
I'm just delaying a little bit
I'm thinking right yeah uh love what did
you think about uh keemstar's uh story
did you believe him well I think it's
entirely possible that he is telling the
truth wow okay A diversity of opinions
so we've all come to different
conclusions here based on the evidence
fascinating our DNA history what is that
term ancestry ancestry
foreign
goes on to brag about his pickup game
which I can only imagine is top tier
he's got top tier dick
top plus top dick Prime penis Prime
penis thank you so Brantley
a game with me where I'm literally
disabled and I'm like uh yo shawty you
looking good and [ __ ] like uh add my
girl on Snapchat
what what bro that's the game I'm
playing bro whoa yeah yeah
what was he talking about what the [ __ ]
I must have to hear that at one again
he's he's at a level where he's telling
people yo he's I imagine him thinking
he's doing this he's like yo shorty i'm
my girl on Snapchat like Brantley is
helping him but wait did he say they
role play where he's handicapped that's
what that's like I'm so lost on that
clip Play It Again role play where she
changed my diapers and [ __ ] I swear
that's what I heard let's try again
so Brantley is playing a game with me
where I'm literally disabled and I'm
like uh Yoshi oh I'm looking good and
[ __ ] he plays a game okay he's literally
disabled okay he's saying when it comes
to picking up girls it's easier for
Brantley he's disabled because he can't
just hit on girls openly because it's
it's cheating if he does it but if she
does it then it's it's I I have a I have
a different Oracle uh I have a different
interpretation I think kind of similar I
think when they go out and pick up women
or whatever High School whatever what
have you uh brantley's like hey see my
friend over there he's disabled you want
to come home with us yeah I can't see
that working track get him a Pity [ __ ]
he's Buffalo Bill he doesn't have long
to live above my arm's broken can you
help me with my van
my friend there he doesn't have long to
live his only dream is to touch a boobie
will you let him touch your boobies uh
Rory
Rory Hicks uh says all the Gnomes
currently living in the Fortress of the
mole folks say keemstar is lying well
there you have it
Rory says the more people are with us we
have a strong fan base in the in the
mole people demographic I gotta I I okay
one more time one more time to unpack
this so Brantley is playing a game with
me where I'm literally disabled and I'm
like uh yo shoda you looking good and
[ __ ] like uh add my girl on Snapchat
that's the game I'm playing bro whoa
yeah yeah
that's what he says in the corner when
they think he's disabled he just starts
screeching like yeah
like like [ __ ] Raymond going off like
I want to burn baby oh wasn't there an
episode of seinfo where everyone was
treating Kramer super nice because they
thought he was like handicapped yeah
because he it's his lips swelled up but
he was wearing shoes they were like
platforms
yeah I'm getting that from that's the
game they play okay interesting Theory
there uh Keem yeah okay uh Kim continues
to obsess over the host's sexuality
calling him so gay let's hear
if not this weekend I will definitely
get [ __ ] there's this here's an
interesting analysis behind every
Epstein there is a Maxwell that was a
interesting analysis perhaps but I
personally wouldn't say that about
Brantley I think she's a sweet girl has
a lot ahead of her nice funny most of
her life yeah don't say anything Keem
said it like the faster though he's
grooming everyone
but but somebody did say uh behind every
Epstein is a Maxwell somebody said that
but that's I think that's too far that's
not even funny
shame on you
[Applause]
it's wrong
it's up at least when I visit Ohio why
do you look like a Power Ranger you're
so gay
I'm not [ __ ] the women here like my
outfit everybody's been complimenting me
there's no women watching this or maybe
there are God I don't know there were
girls on the call like the one that came
with there was the girl on the call
whatever the [ __ ] there was a girl on
the song
closed captioning not available
yeah exactly the women
looks so gay I'm not trying to please
you am I bringing at your gay side or
something
I'm just saying I wouldn't like come on
like for what keemstar one more time if
not this weekend I will definitely get
[ __ ] up at least when I visit Ohio why
do you look like a Power Ranger you're
so gay
I'm not [ __ ] the women here like my
outfit everybody's been complimenting me
the women
it looks so gay I'm not trying to please
you if am I bringing at your gay side or
something
I'm just saying I wouldn't like come on
he's so he's so defeated at the end
there and he says what am I bring what
does being gay look like I'm just saying
Edwin come on I don't that's what I say
it's like from 1995 what does being gay
look like keemstar
a Power Ranger yeah a Power Ranger all
right Power Ranger keemstar jerked off
to the Power Rangers confirmed by the
way ripped to the goat rip to Tom
the black one right was that who got it
no the green right red ranger that
turned into like the white no oh my God
sit down it's the Green Ranger turned
away the original Green Ranger he turned
the white one yes yeah the Chad
who the [ __ ] was the Red Ranger that's
right Jason Jason I think stabbed
someone he's still alive dude those guys
have been a rough ride bro the Power
Rangers and now you got keemstar trying
to [ __ ] him that's the last thing they
need anyways rip to Tommy rip to the
goat that was so sad man
every kid like looked up to him like
that's that's a badass [ __ ] I
want to be like that when I get older
love Tommy thank you to PP Goblin for 10
gifted subbies
love that for you
so keemstar has a opinions that you can
look gay
and he's obsessed about it uh keemstar
says he continues to harass him about
the homosexuality says keemstars says
what are you gay and mango Jewels are
gay who he was just screaming off screen
for
Brantley to bring him jewels
so what flavor uh Jewels you have
[ __ ] tobacco what are you gay
no I was just checking no he was
checking if you're here
yeah
it was a good show it was a good way to
check it's like when you ask a guy to
check their nails
why would they say mango they're gay
just so you know
all right game Star is the
um
Authority
but again this is a conversation I
haven't heard in like 20 years well also
Jewel hasn't made a mango pod in like
five years yeah since like 2017. well he
stopped that keemstar stocked up
you didn't want to run out
also a Seinfeld reference like the
sponge
Elaine with a sponge she didn't stock up
yes he said he thought the mango ones
are gay though yeah he's projecting he's
got a whole [ __ ] oh yeah so I've got
a closet full of man this is Brantley
mango Worthy
you know like probably not I can't
imagine the him sharing those those rare
yeah
there it is um he continues
keemstar says [ __ ] don't want a
skinny dick
and brags about his style okay
interesting let's hear it
[ __ ] do not want a skinny dick
oh God damn it
okay
when does a [ __ ] want a skinny dick
they want a [ __ ] fat dick like what
like dude this man has spent way too
much time talking about fat [ __ ]
questioning this dude's sexuality
it's a lot dude I mean guys
we don't need to know about your fat
dick we all have different things you
know how
is this like there's different sizes of
penises there's different sizes of
vaginas
um being honest this is like the whole
truth uh like people need to know this
because like if you don't know this then
you're just dumb if you say like oh that
[ __ ] is loose no it's just because your
dick is small that's honest like that's
really the truth it doesn't fit facts
spitting right so she's saying and I
hate to be so uh I hate to be so uncouth
about it but it does beg the question is
she implying that she has a large vagina
or small vagina
I don't think she's implying anything
about herself she's insulting men who
say oh that girl's loose or whatever
she's flipping it and being like that
just means you have a tiny dick yeah
because keemstar just said women want a
fat duck [ __ ] though so they seem to be
at odds with each other a little bit
well
they're both very drunk and not very
bright so having the conversation flow
in a coherent matter is
it's a lot to ask well women want fat
[ __ ] came to Star everybody with that
insight and a hot dog that's what it is
that's just what it is do you have a
bigger vagina so you need a bigger
[ __ ] [ __ ] and stuff is it true ladies
in the chat is it true yeah
I think she seems to be implying that
she has a small vagina
and therefore Kim has a you know I'm
just saying am I reading too far into
reading way too far into it okay I'm
just trying to
um untangle this so maybe I'm reading
too far into it we'll move on 90s like
crisscross [ __ ] like um um I'm sorry
can we look at your your pants with the
ripped jeans like okay here's a picture
you mad I look good yeah
[Laughter]
God damn look at that sexy [ __ ]
your sister this is a basic ass outfit
this is exemplary what are you talking
about basic like those shoes do you know
where those shoes are from you don't
know
I'm judging the paintings tight jeans
with a hole in them
are you exactly let them know let them
know [ __ ]
no [ __ ] that doesn't look too cute
it looks kind of gay you're [ __ ]
you're like 40 years old shut up bro he
literally just said she's 40 years old
that's your exact age
I
like he I think he actually thinks he's
18 or something yeah really there's
something
you're 40. shut up something deeper
going on there so are you filler boy
love you Kim all that all your pants
have holes in them
right easier yeah
my heart look at me [ __ ] yeah it's
gorgeous oh I mean Brantley you're
beautiful
I mean look this is this is back in the
keem's shy days earlier this year he was
like a little shy like Keem was like
yeah let's go Daddy
well and look at you who presents it
got that Red Bull low sugar he said he
says I gave I said no so many times but
I gave in I'm not dating this girl
um
yeah she hustled me you're lucky he is
so fine though like look at him though
like bro what I'm sorry I know she's
into her man and that's cool and all but
like
I get my my skin crawl when I hear her
say that
I mean
good for them Different Strokes for
different people they're happy yeah no I
thought yeah I could see someone there's
some being someone's exact type right
like you can imagine that probably wants
to [ __ ] you
let's see let's see brantley's Instagram
did you just make your Instagram oh he
they they accuse our fans of getting her
banned I don't even know what the [ __ ]
you started so it doesn't seem like I'm
avoiding it
h3h3 fans flagged it oh that's messed up
I was like how do I know who flagged it
no stupid nobody's going to her
Instagram stop
stop it
stop it
um they probably thought it was underage
girl in like bikinis and stuff this is a
violation of TOS it's just a guess
makes sense
and finally
this is the final one keemstar
they say keemstar's been getting Botox
and facelifts and he doesn't deny it now
there's nothing wrong with that I like a
youthful King
you know what I mean
maybe he even got that doctor that does
syringe trick shots well the problem is
that he tweets out I will not date
someone that was alive during 9 11. so
right and then he's trying to look young
yeah and he goes he just said to a girl
who's 40 you're 40 shut up right that's
weird it's inconsistent is all
about himself because he he got some uh
was it yeah injections I'm pretty sure
it was
Killers I I am sorry to tell everyone
here listening that I actually love
myself and care about myself Clara does
not
I care about myself so much that I go to
the gym team when do you do last go to
the gym okay
um
[ __ ] I own the gym do you work out you
own the gym you have what do you have in
your gym you have a sleeping xylee
did I kill him where did you go
I walked away to replace my uh Vape but
like this man is making so many excuses
for that Jewel cartridge
if you rip it like constantly about a
day so he so in an hour apparently he
needed a new jewelry
that's awesome
I take care of myself I take care of
everything and it's like it's so
ridiculous bro I live on a diet of
strict beef jerky maple syrup that God
intended
unless that you need these like Clara
W's in the [ __ ] chat to make you feel
good about yourself like you should feel
good about yourself
it is so angry no you're not winning
well Keem needs his validation you know
it's understandable he needs his
validation right
can I talk you've been talking
true okay well go ahead say what you
need to say then
I don't know just I'm just pointing out
while you're over here talking about
somebody's bags I mean it's easy for you
to say it seems how you've had work done
true Queen
see I'm 40 in December and I've never
had a pinch of [ __ ] done that's all
natural that's for me taking care of
myself okay okay snap off not paying
somebody else to do it snap off do you
exercise do you work out
[ __ ] yeah exercise I work out okay when
did you last go to the gym you said on
the king Style Show because I am a
viewer that you haven't been going to
the gym recently that confident I mean
replied to that yeah I haven't yeah
we're gonna be putting into my local gym
wait this is the best excuse ever this
is something that like George Costanza
would say so he hasn't been exercising
this is why I'm waiting for it he said
he owns the gym by the way right here to
be putting into my local gym but like
recently
yeah I haven't because I'm waiting for a
heater to be putting into my local gym
but like oh it's too cold at the local
gym he's waiting for a heater
I get that
they need a heater the local gym
but apparently the Gym's in like a base
a dunk a dungeon Shack it's just a
dungeon made out of stone I thought he
owned it what kind of [ __ ] gym are
you going to bro they don't have like
air conditioning
[Laughter]
thought you were supposed to be rich or
some [ __ ]
why are you going to the Payless
discount job
no AC get you a discount why do you look
like a Power Ranger you're so gay
wait
okay well if I could respond it's like
instantly like you say one thing and
then you just
but like bro ask Brantley ask any [ __ ]
like I'm totally put my work in bro I'm
getting my [ __ ] sit-ups in
sit-ups sit-ups that's that's adorable
great how much can you bench
oh whoa go in there yes
really how much she weigh oh my God
we're talking weights Kim
I'm talking Brantley I've been sure
Bradley how much you weigh 120. we know
that 20. 120 I benched that [ __ ] that's
not that impressive uh is it yeah why is
he call this a girlfriend [ __ ] it's
just like bro because he benches that
[ __ ] is that big it's just not that
cool dude as you think it is
um
there it is so that was the keemstar
Mega experience they tried desperately
to erase it but we got it all uh much to
his displeasure I'm sure and of course
let's not forget
oh bro I met this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight that one is
Gonna Stay Gold and also my other
favorite moment was this was the
Leonardo Dicaprio and two chain storage
you have any good moments there exact
you can you can hit DiCaprio yeah
Leonardo yeah yeah he okay so keemstar
has actually been active he's a fan we
know that he's been on he's been on the
bed in the dark twiddling his toes and
enjoying the show
so he posted a response let's see what
he has to say Ethan Klein hates his fans
oh come on how could you how dare you
say such a thing I love my fans
let's see
you watch this maybe yeah I watched it
okay yeah
before Thanksgiving I mean Brantley
biggest drinking night of that no a
showah ads who didn't confess to finding
high school girls hot it's Labor Day Eve
the biggest drinking day of the Year
everyone for Thanksgiving it's right
it's the biggest trick of night of the
year Hey listen it's the biggest
drinking of the Year somewhere it's two
nights after Flag Day and they get drunk
happy Arbor Day
I mean let's kick some back to be fair
isn't he right about that though thanks
to the night before Thanksgiving I think
I think he's actually what is it maybe
it's maybe listen regardless of who he's
right right still a funny ass thing yeah
I am bigger than New Year's Eve no
[ __ ] shot bigger than Fourth of July
but why the day before Thanksgiving what
about why not because everybody usually
visiting home they're coming back home
let's see what did you drink on
Thanksgiving though that's what yeah I
don't make the rules man did you fact
check that this is blackout Wednesday
also known as drinks giving or first
Thanksgiving the night before
Thanksgiving but yeah I'm not sure if
it's the busiest I would think I would I
guess maybe it's something people say
but I seriously forgot about that I
think it's what alcoholics say yeah
exactly
yeah
hammered and at the bar I was like
hanging out with people that I went to
high school with whatever came home I
noticed Edwin was streaming so I called
oh so he's bothered by the high school
girl comment that's the one that really
got him okay interesting let's see what
he says on the Edwin show all right I
was pretty wasted you know if you want
to pick on me for being cringy or drunk
or whatever [ __ ] by all means I'm
fair game oh oh that's the end we did
that we don't need to watch the rest
we're good we did that yeah he said it's
all good should I keep watching he said
he's got his Blessing it's really sounds
like it's fine okay cool thanks bro all
right
can you imagine he'd be so angry if I
did that that's why you should do it no
I'm gonna watch it bro I'm gonna do it
for you Kim because I believe you man uh
but when I'm trying to explain to Edwin
that I was out hanging out with people
that I went to high school with I said
yeah this girl from high school you
didn't say that you did not say this
girl from high school play it Zach yo
bro I'm at this high school girl that I
was hot as [ __ ] tonight okay so like you
are not being truthful Mr uh Daniel Keem
you that one word it makes a very key
difference tonight Jordan Peterson would
have a lot to say about that what is the
what is the meaning of
I met a girl tonight tonight versus I
met a high school girl
what is high school tonight what is a
girl from high school like meaning that
I went to high school with I said yeah
this girl from high school like meaning
like the girl that I went to high school
with and I
incorrect
you're not being truthful Daniel tonight
speak the truth at least say you
misspoke yeah at least say that but
don't say that we're taken out of
context because that's not true Daniel
don't be naughty Daniel come on be
honest
yeah okay but that's not no that's got
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about that's between you and your doctor
whatever I don't know anything about
that
um if you wanna at least plausibly deny
this you need to say you misspoke
because I'm not buying it at least they
were there for a cupcake ah
a little um EDP lore
EDP is back by the way
oh good did we watch that video on no
without eating a cupcake that shit's
crazy do you see that Dan dude EDP
posted a video of him silently eating a
cupcake The Tick Tock and everyone's
like this is [ __ ] hilarious people
are there for It lyrics
here we go everyone goes wait what and
then I corrected it it was like the girl
that I went to high school with right
yeah so again keemstar you need to be
honest about this you said it
and then you paused for a long time
trying to think of an alternative that's
the way I interpret it in my opinion
it was not that clear where you're like
oh no I meant this come on now Keem be
honest be serious I'm trying to explain
this to him and right away uh Ethan
Klein's fans on the h3h3 Reddit took
that clip out of context and now H3 is
running with it saying see it's weird
he's hanging out with girls from height
just more lies and manipulation I
watched the whole clip like the whole
thing bro
and also are you not dating a girl with
braces who's like 20. hey she literally
just finished high school yeah like I
think we right like a year I don't know
but it's like it's not just being pulled
out of the ether man it's not slander to
say that you date young women right and
this is this no he literally this is the
guy who tweeted if you don't remember
yeah if you remember 911 it the tweet's
still up by the way he never deleted
that wait how old would you be when 9 11
happened
me no just in general if you remember
911 you'd have to be at least
three or four years old so let's say
three like probably even older to like
actually remember I don't know yeah so
I'm just trying to see what's the age
limit there if that's the joke
so 911 happened how long ago what year
was that 2001. yeah I was I was 21 years
ago damn that [ __ ] was long ago [ __ ] yes
sir 21. I just want to point out that at
the time of making this I checked the
subreddit and there was not a single
post about it I don't think anybody's
talked about it
at the time of him making his video
right I don't know if they added no
there was a post I saw it
there was a post on the subreddit for
this clip no no I'm saying when he made
this saying immediately the fans went to
their stuff oh no yeah yeah no this one
under the radar for a minute he got his
friend to delist it or remember it only
or whatever he did
um keemstar you're lying come on I
watched the whole thing I'm being so
fair so objective I'm giving you all the
benefits of the doubt people are saying
you forgot
everyone said they would never forget
you forgot you forgot you didn't know
what that'll ever happen I mean I
remember it happened I just don't
remember you know exactly we said never
forget well maybe it's better I remember
it forget everything involving you know
now you're living yeah that type of
stuff
I remember it [ __ ] yo stings you
seriously just were admitted to not
remembering bro
how could you say that yo
stinge you just ruined your own life
dude anyway let's see what Kim starts
saying this is important I want to give
him the floor H3 is running with it
saying see it's weird he's hanging out
with girls from height just more lies
and manipulation because at the end of
the day if you're an h3h3 fan like
you're not respected you're not loved if
you were respected and you were loved
you wouldn't be lied to and manipulated
like this right use this little Pawn to
fight a fat man's [ __ ] arguments
Batman
he called me fast
he said the thing
he said fat man and debates online if
you were actually loved and cherished
you would be told the truth not lies out
of context
right he's true that's a good point I do
hate the fans because apparently I
didn't I didn't help uh play defense for
a dude who fantasizes about high school
girls
so I apologize for not loving you guys
enough
when you come to Buffalo and I'll hook
you up this was not convincing and the
slightest like I want to give you the
platform to defend yourself because the
accusations are pretty severe here it's
pretty embarrassing it's pretty bad and
yes while I am fat I do think that I've
made a pretty fair analysis of this now
you need to say if you want to deny this
that you misspoke
you misspoke
but I did not take it out of context sir
those are your words Zach
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight
I met
this high school girl
Play One More Time Zach yeah bro I'm at
this high school girl that I was hot as
[ __ ] tonight
he met this high school girl yeah I mean
met this high school girl who's hot as
[ __ ] but he said now just to re rerun
the evidence he says he said this bar
was like hanging out with people that I
went to high school with whatever came
home I noticed Edwin was streaming so I
called and I wouldn't have met all right
I was pretty you just wouldn't say Matt
you would you ran into I ran into this
girl I knew in high school or I ran into
this high school girl like even that
could be interpreted as like oh you're
just drunken you kind of stumbled over
your words but met I met meet meetings I
met this high school girl I don't know
yo bro I met this high school girl that
I was hot as [ __ ] tonight yeah okay but
let's hear what he says you know if you
want to pick on me for being cringy or
drunk or whatever [ __ ] by all means
I'm fair game uh but when I'm trying to
explain to Edwin that I was out hanging
out with people that I went to high
school with I said yeah this girl from
high school like meaning like the girl
that I went to high school with and I
wouldn't goes wait what and then I
corrected it it was like the girl that I
went to hike yeah that's not what you
said I mean we can play it side by side
here let's hear what he says if you find
yourself having to make this video
you've already you [ __ ] up you did you
[ __ ] up you're standing and you I've
never literally made that I've never
misunderstanding I've never had the need
let me let me clarify here okay real
quick trying to explain to Edwin that I
was out hanging out with people that I
went to high school with I said yeah
this girl from high school like meaning
like the girl that I go ahead I'm not
this high school girl that I was hottest
he different yeah I know that's
different that's different also he was
very Stern with the yo bro I met I met
present tense yo bro I met this high
school girl that I was hot as [ __ ]
you're gonna have to do better bro
you're gonna have to do better to
explain this one okay
but anyway thanks for um thanks for
trying thanks for trying thanks for
calling more attention to it too Keem it
was very smart of you that's interesting
that tweeted out that video oh my God
I'm sorry but he pinned this
he pinned this [ __ ]
dude you're so sad dude that's okay
Ethan Klein H3 podcast he misspelled my
last name I don't know if he's doing it
on purpose or if he's just
he tag team YouTube too we love that
Forum second time this year calling for
terrorist attacks
team YouTube proving is the only
YouTuber calling for mass murder and
violence
still be taken down why hashtag
dramaalert he's he's uh
he's pinned that Chad is Right chat is
right I'm disabled
I didn't say that that was that was your
words but yeah so here he is uh if you
have more to say Kim
then I'd be happy to to play it okay but
uh oh there's there's a new one
yeah just if you want to tweet I'll look
at it dude
um here he says this is a response he's
responding to people
damn he's he's dropping responses with
two likes that's pretty embarrassing
didn't people used to watch drum alert
uh someone says calm your titties they
are showing the original stream yeah I
showed the whole thing
um they always lie truth scares them
okay whatever
anyway there you go that was the
Christmas miracle it was so much fun I'm
so glad despite what keemstar alleges I
love you guys and it was just so it was
so so happy to share this moment with
you guys on this beautiful Monday I
think keemstar was praying to the
YouTube Gods we got banned so we
couldn't talk about this because he knew
he knew hey there was coming
what you want what what were we talking
about keemstar's last drama alert was
posted a month ago and it has a 113
000 views that's crazy though didn't he
I mean first of all that's good right I
don't wanna I don't want a demean that I
mean that's a lot of people to watch
your video but wasn't he getting like a
million views per video like back in the
day and no like earlier this year no
free Aiden raw [ __ ] he was popping yeah
that Aidan Ross thing was last year oh
it was that long ago yeah yeah oh that
was last year's gift oh my God that was
all the way last year yeah dude
whoa it's been a minute yo you're in
trouble that crypto well then to be fair
a hundred thousand per video is actually
pretty good considering the Aiden Rock
everything he's been through yeah that
means 100 000 people still watch this
video bro
who they saw the aid in Russia and they
decided they still like you
that's that's that's pretty dope that's
real fandom right there man we have
brighter guys
mom meatloaf
where's that me low [ __ ]
he said I think he's more popular on
Snapchat well that's where he belongs so
that makes sense
that's the app you used to or some
people have used to pick up young kids
right because the combos get uh erased
uh right that's not him
not him
some people use Snapchat yeah like that
was where James Charles was sisters and
Chris Delia got busted on there or
whatever not him I'm not saying he does
that I'm just saying he's popular on
Snapchat yeah I was just making it which
is the ass a little that people some
people use yeah
that we talk
it's time we talk
all right um we have been almost going
for uh uh three hours yeah I think it's
about time but I'm really looking
forward to that Elon Musk unbanned I
should get I should get the um
you should get elon's Grace so
you know there it is oh right
uh I don't I always think about it some
more I don't think so I don't think
you're gonna get unbanned and not
necessarily because you're being
specifically targeted what I I have a
feeling that their Mass on band is gonna
not include the wave of suspensions for
impersonation that they've done but he
said only spam I know what he said but I
I have a feeling you're not gonna get
unbanned and neither will anybody else
who did that
uh what about Ela because she got banned
for uh band evasion that's got nothing
to do with impersonating
so she should technically get on band
maybe maybe
I mean we'll see if it even happens the
thing is if me and Ila stay banned
that's very suspicious
yeah I guess we'll have to just look
keep an eye out for some of the other
accounts that got swept up in that same
uh
yeah people are saying he unbanned Kathy
Griffin yeah but he did that
at the same time that he unbanned who
was it I think it was Kanye and Trump
Kanye it was Jordan Peterson
babe I find it so funny that he made a
baby this is how you know Elon Musk is a
conservative [ __ ] back he made this big
showing of unbanning Jordan Peterson
Jordan Peterson was never banned all he
had to do was erase a [ __ ] like like
violently transphobic yeah he was locked
out he wasn't banned yeah so like why do
you even just give him a shout out like
he wasn't banned so [ __ ] stupid dude
so stupid those are stupid oh this is
interesting you know Shutter Island
um was that popular uh Leonardo one I
wonder if this is
this is possibly what went down there
Shutter Island Jaeger food chains and
keemstar some places never let you go
Naruto DiCaprio Kim why don't you talk
about this interview no if you know the
plot of that movie yeah that is anything
more appropriate yeah actually I don't
well then I'll tell you after this yeah
because I don't want but if anybody
hasn't seen that movie I don't think it
matters but okay guys what a fun good
time we had I love you all so much don't
listen to keemstar I love you guys he
doesn't know anything about us
let's get the holidays going right man
kicking it off and uh we have actually
so much fun episodes coming up leading
up to December 20th our final show
thank you guys all for your support two
members tomorrow at 12 o'clock we are
doing see you next Tuesday live stream
for members
I'm looking forward to that
I'm not retiring
thank you for asking
all right guys Tata love y'all see you
on tomorrow or Wednesday bye bye
[Music]